in verschiedenen ukrainischen Städten
die russische Armee bombardiert
Stellungen im ganzen Land es gibt
Luftangriffe Flughäfen werden getroffen
panzerrollen
und diese Putin das ist
so ich habe nicht schlecht gesagt aber
das ist mein herzin und meine ganze
Familie ist da nur und meine Nachbarin
allem ist da nur ja ist heute
telefoniere meine Kinder ist ein auch
rein alle muss nach Deutschland zurück
Strafe Sanktionen noch mehr noch mehr
weil die Russland muss raus auf unsere
Lande ja Angst und Verzweiflung waren da
zu spüren guten Abend und willkommen zum
zdf-spezial an diesem 24 Februar 2022
der auf furchtbare Weise zum
historischen Datum geworden ist
russlands Präsident Putin hat den
Überfall auf die unabhängige Ukraine
befohlen nicht aus Notwehr sondern in
einem Akt offener Aggression aufgrund
dieser aktuellen Ereignisse verzichten
wir auf die Ausstrahlung von kölle Alaaf
die Mädchensitzung hier im Hauptprogramm
die aufgezeichnete Sitzung können Sie
heute ab 20 Uhr in der ZDF Mediathek
sehen
innerhalb dieser Spezialsendung hier
wird meine Kollegin Maybrit Illner
Gesprächsrunden in Berlin haben Peter
frei und Bettina Schausten werden in
wenigen Minuten die
bundesaußenministerin Fragen was nun vor
baerbock wir halten Sie über alle
fortlaufenden Ereignisse auf dem
Laufenden
seit dem frühen Morgen läuft der Angriff
Russlands unter anderem mit Beschuss der
Regionen um Lemberg und Tschernobyl der
Hauptstadt Kiew im Osten auf Harke und
krematorsk sowie die Hafenstädte Mario
Paul und Odessa
zunächst aber ein kurzer Einspielfilm
der die Chronologie dieses Tages für Sie
zusammenfasst
ich habe die Entscheidung für eine
Militäroperation getroffen um Menschen
zu schützen die seit acht Jahren einem
Völkermord durch das Regime in Kiew
ausgesetzt waren
Vladimir Putin überfällt die Ukraine in
den frühen Morgenstunden mehrere Städte
werden angegriffen aus der Luft vom
Boden und vom Wasser aus der ukrainische
Präsident selenski fängt das Kriegsrecht
und ruft in einer Videobotschaft gegen
5:30 Uhr dazu auf nicht in Panik zu
verfallen man sei auf alles vorbereitet
und werde siegen in der Hauptstadt Kiew
heulen die Sirenen Bombenalarm Trümmer
liegen in einer Geschäftsstraße herum
die Menschen realisieren es ist Krieg
[Musik]
zuerst hörte ich eine furchtbare
Explosion mit unglaublicher Gewalt ich
sprang auf und ich wusste nicht wohin
ich gehen sollte ich bekam Panik
9:45 Uhr
bundesaußenministerin baerbock tritt vor
die Presse verurteilt mit scharfen
Worten den russischen Einmarsch mit dem
militärischen Angriff auf die Ukraine
bricht die russische Regierung vor den
Augen der Welt mit den elementarsten
Regeln der internationalen Ordnung auch
Harke die zweitgrößte Stadt der Ukraine
ist Ziel der Angriffe
raketensplitter bohren sich durch die
Decke dieser Wohnung die Menschen
fürchten sich suchen Schutz in den
Stationen der Metro
unterdessen bilden sich an Kiews
Tankstellen und Banken lange Schlangen
die Straßen der Hauptstadt verstopft die
Menschen wollen nur noch weg etliche
folgen dem Aufruf des Gesundheitsamtes
freiwillig Blut zu spenden
13 Uhr in Brüssel warnen
Nato-Generalsekretär Stoltenberg und
eu-kommissionspräsidentin von der Leyen
die Sicherheit Europas sei in Gefahr
das ist barbarisch wir verurteilen das
aufs Äußerste es geht hier um die
Stabilität von Europa und Welt um unsere
Friedensordnung
am Nachmittag kommen diese Bilder eine
Schlangen an den Kassen eines großen
Supermarktes leere Regale die Menschen
reagieren mit Panikkäufen
Mitbürgerinnen und mit um 18 Uhr wendet
sich Bundeskanzler Scholz direkt an die
Fernsehzuschauer gerade erleben wir den
Beginn eines Krieges wie wir in Europa
so seit mehr als 75 Jahren nicht erlebt
haben
russlands Präsident Putin hat die
Entscheidung getroffen die Ukraine
militärisch anzugreifen das ist ein
Überfall auf ein unabhängiges souveränes
Land
es durch nichts und durch niemanden
zurechtfertigen
bei wuniza etwa 250 Kilometer
südwestlich von Kiew ist unser Reporter
Axel Storm mit seinem Team unterwegs
Axel wie hat sich die Lage denn in den
letzten Stunden entwickelt was haben sie
selbst gesehen und was hören sie aus der
Ukraine insgesamt
ja die Lage entwickelt sich im Prinzip
auf minutenbasis Weiter und es kursieren
unheimlich viele Meldungen viele von
denen sind natürlich nicht überprüfbar
aber vielleicht mal die letzten
zusammengefasst also das verunglückte
Kernkraftwerk Tschernobyl soll
inzwischen in russischer Hand sein es
gab wohl stundenlange Gefechte um den
Standort inzwischen scheint Russland
dort die Hoheit gewonnen zu haben es
gibt Berichte darüber dass ukrainische
Soldaten
den Dienst quittieren ihre Waffen
wegwerfen und fliehen vor der russischen
Übermacht russisch belarussischen
Übermacht muss man ja sagen denn
russland hat ja in Belarus ein
Verbündeten bei diesem aggress
aggressiven Angriff wir selbst haben
erlebt heute morgen in Kiew
Bombenalarm zwischen 3:30 und 4 Uhr gab
es die ersten schweren Detonation wir
und zwar am Anfang gar nicht klar ob das
möglicherweise irgendwelche
baustellengeräusche sind aber sie waren
so massiv dass wir dann doch
aufgestanden sind und aufgebrochen sind
wir auch fürs Morgenmagazin gearbeitet
in Kiew auf der Straße haben noch
berichtet über die über das Verhalten
der Menschen die meisten Menschen sind
sehr eilig unterwegs gewesen waren mit
Koffern schon unterwegs es war noch
keine Panik aber man hatte das Gefühl
okay da ist Bewegung drin und jetzt in
den letzten Stunden kamen auch die
Meldung dass in Kiew den ganzen Tag über
Fliegeralarm ausgestrahlt wurde dass
Tausende von Menschen versuchen die
ukrainische Hauptstadt zu verlassen und
so haben auch wir die Hauptstadt
verlassen heute morgen zwischen 8 und 9
Uhr und haben uns auf den Weg in den
Südwesten gemacht um die Sicherheitslage
für uns und unser Team neu zu bewerten
ja eine Fluchtbewegung also vor allen
Dingen raus aus den Städten die
besonders gefährdet sind vielen Dank für
diese Eindrücke Axel storm
[Musik]
vor einer halben Stunde war die
bundesaußenministerin im Gespräch bei
Peter Frey und Bettina Schausten das
schauen wir uns jetzt an und kommen
direkt danach zurück hierher ins Studio
mit weiteren aktuellen Informationen und
Gesprächen zunächst aber was nun Frau
bärbock
was nun Frau Bär Bock Russland führt nun
einen Angriffskrieg gegen die Ukraine
hat heute abend womöglich schon die
Außenbezirke von Kiew erreicht und ist
dabei das ganze Land zu erobern dort
einzumarschieren aus ihrer Sicht gibt es
noch einen Weg Putin zu stoppen
das was in diesen Stunden Minuten
passiert ist macht ein fassungslos macht
ein fassungslos nicht sprachlos deswegen
haben wir heute auch so deutlich gesagt
dass das mit jeglichen Grundlagen nicht
nur das Völkerrecht sondern das
menschlichen
zusammenlebensbericht und wir tun jetzt
alles dafür Menschen in Sicherheit zu
bringen deutsche Staatsangehörige aber
natürlich auch die Menschen die
Ukrainerinnen und Ukrainer die jetzt
über die polnische Grenze kommen und vor
diesen Angriffen fliehen der Westen wird
heute noch weitere Sanktionen auch
verhängen das ist jedenfalls Ziel auch
eines Gipfels aber davon lässt Putin
sich ja offenbar nicht beeindrucken
jedenfalls haben die Drohungen der
letzten Tage und Wochen ihn ja nicht
aufhalten können deshalb noch mal die
Frage welchen Weg gibt es noch ihn zu
stoppen oder können wir am Ende im
Moment nur noch zusehen wie er die
Ukraine sich einverleibt
in diesem Minuten so furchtbar dass ist
erleben wie wir wie Stück für Stück die
Truppen russische Truppen vor
marschieren wir erleben aber auch dass
es Widerstand von Seiten der Ukraine
gibt da Sie angesprochen haben das hat
ja offensichtlich in den letzten Tagen
nicht so mit diplomatischen Beziehungen
funktioniert muss man sich glaube ich
noch mal vergegenwärtigen was für ein
Rede der russische Präsident gehalten
hat also da war nichts von einem handeln
was unseren Grundlagen von rationaler
politischer Verantwortung entspricht
sondern vollkommen entgrenztes agieren
wenn man einem anderen Land was ja
eigentlich so eng auch kulturell mit
familiären Beziehungen miteinander
verbunden ist das existenzrechte
abspricht dann macht das deutlich dass
er gewillt ist offensichtlich mit allen
Mitteln und zwar mit allen Mitteln
selbst wenn das der Bruch mit allen
nicht nur politischen völkerrechtlichen
sondern menschlichen Regeln ist diesen
Vormarsch jetzt voranzutreiben konnte er
ist nicht zu stoppen wenn man sich mal
die Räder anguckt nicht mehr die vor
zwei Tagen sondern auch die von heute
Nacht dann hat er ja nicht nur den
Angriff auf die Ukraine befohlen mit
dieser Rede und begonnen sondern
gleichzeitig den Westen uns vor
Konsequenzen gewarnt Zitat Konsequenzen
wie sie Europa noch nicht gesehen hat
und er sagte wörtlich wir sind zu allen
bereit wie verstehen sie das Frau
Bedburg ist das eine unverhohlene
Drohung von Putin selbst mit Atomwaffen
und auch gegen uns
das menschenverachtend muss man sagen
wenn man mit allen bereit ist dass
Menschenleben von jeglichen Kindern
Frauen Männern aufs Spiel zu setzen um
seine Wahnvorstellungen durchzusetzen
dann ist es menschenverachtend und auf
der anderen Seite macht das so deutlich
es geht eben nicht nur um die Ukraine
das haben sie ja auch mit angesprochen
es geht um die europäische
Friedensordnung es geht aber auch um die
politische Auseinandersetzung und die
wird weitergehen und deswegen ist es
auch so wichtig dass wir jetzt
geschlossen sagen wir akzeptieren das
nicht als Weltgemeinschaft nicht nur als
Europäerin und Europäer weil hier steht
ja nicht nur Russland was die Ukraine
angreift sondern hier steht ein
Verständnis freie liberale Demokratien
und auf der anderen Seite ein
autoritäres Regime dem offensichtlich
jegliche Mittel recht sind um seine
machtvorstellungen durchzusetzen und
diese freie liberale Demokratien das
müssen wir verteidigen wir müssen das
völkerrechte verteidigen und deutlich
machen das ist die Grundlage der
internationalen Gemeinschaft und
deswegen bin ich dieser Minuten auch
angesichts dieser Bilder
mit allem daran deutlich zu machen wir
reagieren darauf mit anderen Partnern
mit Außenministern weltweit im Gespräch
zu sagen ihr müsst euch jetzt euch sein
wir müssen als Weltgemeinschaft zeigen
wir nehmen das als Welt nicht hin damit
diese Auseinandersetzung über das
internationale Recht eine Grad klare
Grenze erhält wir nehmen das nicht hin
sagen Sie jetzt hört man heute
allerdings auch schon viel Selbstkritik
aus der deutschen Politik auch
Vizekanzler Habeck sagt der besten seit
naiv gewesen im Umgang mit Putin die
frühere Verteidigungsministerin
Kramp-Karrenbauer sie werden das gelesen
haben beklagt dass man eben in den
letzten Jahren nicht ausreichend Mittel
aufgebaut hätte und Putin abzuschrecken
ziehen Sie auch den Schluss heute Abend
das im Grunde jetzt die deutsche
russland-politik der letzten Jahrzehnte
muss man sagen am Ende ist
was ich erstmal wichtig finde weil auch
das ein Teil dieser großen Strategie ist
und das dürfen wir nicht unterschätzen
es geht wie gesagt auch um die große
Strategie in der Welt eine ein narrative
zu verbreiten dass er sagt er auch immer
der Westen hätte hier
eskaliert nein es ist Russland was
allein die Verantwortung dafür trägt und
deswegen ist so wichtig die
Geschlossenheit weil sie hat gefragt
haben die deutsche die deutsche
Verantwortung als Europäer haben wir in
der Vergangenheit gehandelt auch mit
Blick auf die russlandfrage das habe ich
in der Vergangenheit ja auch deutlich
gemacht zum Beispiel ein ausstream 2
dass wir eben hinter Energie Lieferung
nicht nur Energielieferungen sehen
sondern die geostrategische Frage die
dahinter steht aber jetzt zu sagen was
ist damals falsch gelaufen ja das müssen
wir uns genau anschauen nur in diesem
Moment gilt es dafür einzustehen dass
wir verteidigen was unsere
internationale Zusammenarbeit ist und
das ist das internationale Recht sie
haben von Wahnvorstellungen gesprochen
bei Putin eben in diesem Gespräch und
das Drehbuch nachdem er jetzt handelt
war doch vorhersehbar und bekannt das
begann mit Georgien die Grimm seine
revisionistischen reden hat jeder hören
können aber sie sind doch auch im Westen
von dem sie jetzt Geschlossenheit hören
erfordern weitgehend ignoriert worden
Deutschland hat doch bis zuletzt
geglaubt durch Frieden durch Dialog
durch Verständigung sozusagen Putin
stoppen zu können war das nicht sogar
mehr als Naivität war das ein Signal der
Schwäche das Putin jetzt als Einladung
zu dieser Aggression verstanden hat
Ja und Nein offensichtlich war es so
dass das was jetzt passiert ist schon
seit längerem einem Skript gefolgt ist
und auf der anderen Seite ist der Punkt
wenn man vollkommen entgrenzt handelt
und auf der anderen Seite wir sind die
sagen für uns gibt es natürlich Grenzen
dass man mit einem reinen narrativ
dagegen zu halten wir müssen alles
doppelt so hart machen wird man nicht
erfolgreich sein sondern dann haben wir
ein komplett grenzenloses handeln und
deswegen ist für mich der wichtige Punkt
diese internationale Geschlossenheit
deutlich zu machen wir isolieren
Russland das haben wir in der
Vergangenheit um auf Ihre Frage zu
kommen das haben wir in der
Vergangenheit offensichtlich nicht klar
und deutlich genug gesagt ist und auch
nicht klar und deutlich genug gemacht
eine Kritik an ihren Vorgängern an
Merkel an Schröder an der ganzen
deutschen russland-politik wissen sie
deswegen ich da jetzt nicht darauf
eingehen will nicht weil ich sage man
muss nicht reflektieren was in der
Vergangenheit nicht gut gelaufen ist
aber jetzt ist der absolut falsche
Moment wo man aus meiner Sicht mit den
Finger gezeigt was sie andere Regierung
gemacht habt sondern ich finde es jetzt
so wichtig und das erleben wir gerade
dass wir zwischen
Opposition und Regierung ganz
geschlossen stehen und alle die Union
alle die im Parlament sind deutlich
sagen hier handelt ein Land und zwar ein
Mann ein Staatschef alleine auf Kosten
von Menschen leben sie hatten das
angesprochen mit der Krim ich würde es
gerne mal ausführen weil Krieg klingt so
abstrakt aber ich war ja vor einigen
Tagen an der kontaktlinie und zwar mit
der stellvertretenden ukrainischen
Außenministerin mein alter die hat auch
eine Tochter sie hat mir da in der
kontaktlinie erzählt meine Tochter hat
ihre Großeltern seit Jahren nicht
gesehen weil wir auf der Krim gelebt
haben sie wurde vertrieben sie wurde als
Persona non grata erklärt das heißt sie
wurde einmal vertrieben und jetzt steht
diese Außenministerin mit ihrer Tochter
erneut Jahre danach vor der Situation
das Putin erklärt hat er will die
Staatsführung im eliminieren und und das
ist jetzt so ein Moment deswegen ich
sage ich fange jetzt nicht an zu sagen
was in der Vergangenheit
Regierung vorher falsch gemacht worden
sind natürlich müssen wir auch
reflektieren aber jetzt müssen wir vor
allen Dingen dafür sorgen dass wir den
Menschen den wir überhaupt noch Schutz
geben können wirklich auch Schutz geben
und wie gesagt deutlich machen wir
akzeptieren diesen massiven Bruch des
Völkerrechts nicht und sie sind jetzt in
der Verantwortung wenn man da mal nach
vorne schauen wenn sie sagen Russland
isolieren dann ist es doch jetzt ihre
Aufgabe Russland eben nicht mehr als
Partner nicht mehr auf Kooperation zu
setzen sondern als Gegner zu sehen kommt
auf sie da auch die Aufgabe zu so eine
Art Gleichgewichtes Schreckens
wiederherzustellen wir haben heute den
Kanzler gehört nicht zurück in den
Kalten Krieg aber immerhin war es doch
ein System der funktionierenden
Abschreckung sage ich mal kommt das auf
sie zu eine neue russland-ordnung der
Russlandpolitik
also zum einen weil ihre Frage war muss
man jetzt nicht da mal deutlich sagen
Russland nicht mehr als Partner zu
verstehen das habe ich das hat diese
Bundesregierung das haben wir Europäer
sehr sehr deutlich in den letzten Wochen
und Monaten gesagt man muss klar sagen
wir wurden belogen wir haben gesagt wir
haben einen Weg der Härte und das
Dialoges weil das unser Verständnis
davon ist von einem friedlichen
Miteinander in der Nachbarschaft immer
auf Dialog zu setzen und ja da muss man
ehrlich sagen wir wurden eiskalt belogen
der Kanzler wurde belogen ich war vom
russischen Außenminister die gesamte
internationale Gemeinschaft aber das ist
doch dann der Punkt wenn man an dem ist
zu sagen weil der eine lügt lügen wir
jetzt auch nein das machen wir nicht wir
stehen zu unseren Werten ein und
zugleich sind wir klar und deutlich dass
wir erleben wir müssen auch Härte zeigen
deswegen verstärken wir jetzt die
Truppen an der nato-außengrenze mit
unseren Verbündeten deswegen machen wir
deutlich wir werden nicht akzeptieren
dass es zu weiteren Mass die
Verletzungen des Völkerrechts kommt aber
sich auf ein Spiel einzulassen von
jemand der sich an keine Regeln hält
dann zu sagen wir halten uns auch nicht
mehr an Regeln das wäre aus meiner Sicht
der falsche Weg weil dann hätte Putin
gewonnen er will die internationale
Ordnung er will das Verständnis von
einer Staatengemeinschaft die auf Regeln
basiert kaputt machen und das ist wie
gesagt der größere Teil seines Spiels
Ukraine ist nur ein Teil davon brauchen
wir nur mehr Geschlossenheit oder
brauchen wir nicht wirklich mehr
glaubwürdige militärische Abschreckung
und bedeutet das für die Grünen nicht
auch in der Abkehr von ihrem bisherigen
Kurs
da wäre meine Rückfrage von welchem
bisherigen Kurs wir haben klar in den
letzten Wochen habe ich ja gerade gesagt
mit Blick auf die NATO unsere
Einsatzfähigkeit auch die schnelle
Einsatzfähigkeit
verstärkt wir haben alle Vorbereitungen
dafür getroffen der Weg auf der einen
Seite Dialog und auf der anderen Seite
Härte ist aus meiner Sicht der richtige
Weg wir erleben aber wenn wir die
Bundeswehr anschauen zum Beispiel dass
wir mit Blick auf Material natürlich
deutlich deutlich mehr machen müssen
wenn wir sagen wir müssen auch unsere
Soldaten in Einsätze schicken bzw unsere
Soldaten verstärken jetzt im Baltikum
dann müssen die natürlich auch so
ausgestattet sein dass die Materialien
dafür zur Verfügung stehen und diese
Diskussion haben wir schon ein bisschen
länger dass wir mit Blick auf die
Beschaffung in Deutschland definitiv
besser werden müssen besser werden
müssen der der heeresinspektor ist da
noch ein bisschen deutlicher heute er
kritisiert sehr scharf die Optionen der
Bundeswehr sein extrem limitiert das
heerstehe wir fixiert wird mehr oder
weniger blank da wie soll man da jetzt
so schnell reagieren Frau bärbock die
verteidigungspläne für Osteuropa sind
aktiviert worden von der NATO und da
sind ja auch stehen Erwartungen an
Deutschland im Raum genau und diese
Erwartung erfüllen wir jetzt gemeinsam
man
alles was wir haben stellen wir zurzeit
zur Verfügung das hat die
Verteidigungsministerin ja auch deutlich
gesagt ich finde in solchen
Krisensituationen Transparenz total
wichtig deswegen haben wir zum Beispiel
gesagt als die Frage kam könnt ihr uns
weitere Materialien wie Schutzwesten und
weiteres liefern zu sagen wir würden
gerne liefern wir können es nicht weil
wir es gerade selber nicht in den in
Beständen haben und das was bekannt war
wo man leider in den letzten Jahren zu
wenig getan hat dass man gerade bei der
Beschaffung besser geworden ist das muss
sich jetzt ändern aber der Punkt ist ja
wir sind jetzt vor der Situation dass
wir manche Dinge nicht haben das heißt
wir müssen Sie jetzt schnell kaufen und
alles was wir beitragen können jetzt im
Rahmen der NATO beitragen und das tun
wir auch das hat die
Sie möglicherweise auch heute Abend und
in den nächsten Tagen noch stehen nicht
zuletzt unter dem Druck der Grünen und
dabei würde ich erstmal bleiben sie sind
ja eine pazifistisch orientierte Partei
hat die Bundesregierung ja daran
festgehalten dem Land der Ukraine keine
Waffen zu liefern nicht einmal offensiv
Waffen nicht einmal Waffen aus alten
DDR-Beständen heute wird viel von
Solidarität gesprochen mit der Ukraine
vom Bundeskanzler auch von ihnen ist
hier ein Umdenken möglich auch in
Richtung Lieferung von Waffen an die
Ukraine auch hier würde ich gerne weil
wir in einer wirklichen Krisensituation
sind und dieses Format ja schwarz oder
weiß das trifft in solchen Situationen
überhaupt nicht zu sondern ist
brandgefährlich weil sie jetzt gesagt
haben pazifistische Partei der Grünen
wurden wir vor 40 Jahren gegründet
deswegen unser klares Bekenntnis mit
Blick auf das Völkerrecht dass wir
Militär nutzen um schlimmste
Völkerrechtsverbrechen zu verhindern
1998 auch gemacht 99 im Fall Kosovo und
Serbien ohne UN-Mandat deutsche Flieger
dorthin was tun sie heute für die
Ukraine können Sie sich vorstellen ein
solches Tabu das ist es doch für sie zu
brechen kein Tabu aus Prinzip sondern
wenn man sagt damit können wir
schlimmstes verhindern oder gute Dinge
tun wir erleben gerade das Russland der
Ukraine militärisch vollkommen überlegen
ist deswegen sie haben jetzt Dinge
angesprochen oder leicht angedeutet mit
Blick auf die Haubitzen die Haubitzen
würden in dieser Situation nichts ändern
sie haben selber gesagt aus Beständen 30
Jahre alt ich habe mir das genau
angeguckt weil ich mir natürlich jeden
Punkt in den letzten Wochen immer wieder
den Kopf zerbrochen haben was können wir
tun aber nicht als Selbstwert damit ich
jetzt hier in ihrer Sendung sagen kann
ich als Deutsche Außenministerin habe
und weiß ganz genau die Faktor des 0,0
Sicherheit gebracht sondern hätte nur
davon abgelenkt meine Zeit für diese
Lieferung einzusetzen anstatt meine
Zeiten darauf zu verwenden was können
wir tun finanziell alle Mittel
bereitzustellen um Hilfe in der Ukraine
zu leisten diese Haubitzen sind 30 Jahre
alt die können noch nicht mal auf dem
Panzer gebaut werden deswegen wäre das
einfach nur eine fast gewesen deswegen
haben wir gesagt das ist für uns jetzt
nicht der richtige Fokus aber man hat
den Eindruck jetzt schon was in Bewegung
kommt wenn man so ein paar Stimmen auch
aus der Sozialdemokratie heute gehört
hat etwa vom SPD-Chef glauben Sie dass
das Thema jetzt noch mal kommt und man
dann am Ende doch zu einer zu einer
Position findet defensiv Waffen müssen
möglich sein wenn es jetzt auch zu spät
kommt im Grunde für die Ukraine
also zum einen die Trennung zwischen
defensiv und offensiv Waffen führt aus
meiner Sicht in die Irre deswegen wir
reden allgemein über Waffen mit Waffen
kann man sich verteidigen sie können
auch zum Angriff genutzt werden das
haben wir in anderen Situationen gesehen
zum Beispiel auch im Irak wenn Waffen
geliefert werden sagt man die wurden zur
Verteidigung genutzt dann wurden Städte
eingenommen die Waffen waren da wurden
von anderen offensiv genutzt deswegen
wir reden über Rüstungsexporte die man
immer nur im Einzelfall entscheiden kann
und die Bundesregierung die neue
Bundesregierung wir haben ja gesagt wir
werden das rüstungsexportkontrollgesetz
überprüfen wir werden weitere
Verschärfungen einziehen da wo wir
nämlich bisher viele viele Fragen haben
warum Waffen an Regime gehen die
Menschenrechte nicht einhalten auf der
anderen Seite nicht
auf der anderen Seite auf der anderen
Seite natürlich macht man Politik immer
vor den vor dem Hintergrund was in der
Realität passiert deswegen wird
natürlich in diesen Debatten jetzt genau
diese Erfahrung auch mit mit einfließen
aber
jetzt in diesem Moment müssen wir uns
darauf fokussieren das ist meine
Verantwortung als deutsche
Außenministerin alles dafür zu tun dass
die Menschen denen gerade schlimmstes
angetan wird dass wir sie so
unterstützen können dass möglichst
wenige zu Schaden kommt plus auch meine
Verantwortung als deutsche
Außenministerin die für die Sicherheit
der deutschen Staatsangehörigen zu
sorgen derzeit sind rund 700 deutsche
Staatsangehörige noch in der Ukraine wir
wissen nicht ob alle sich in unsere
Listen eingetragen haben deswegen möchte
ich hier an dieser Stelle auch noch mal
sagen wir haben eine Telefonhotline
geschaltet für diejenigen die nach
Deutschland kommen wollen an den Grenzen
stehen an der Grenze stehen Beamte des
Auswärtigen Amtes die sich dann
natürlich auch auch das haben wir
vorbereitet im europäischen Kontakt um
die Ukrainerinnen und Ukrainer kümmern
die jetzt in Europa Sicherheit suchen
werden sie haben von Dialog und Härte
gesprochen kann Diplomatie jetzt noch
was ausrichten haben Sie ganz konkret
mal gefragt noch ein Gesprächsfaden etwa
ihrem Kollegen lavrov na ich habe am
Montag mit Herrn lawrov telefoniert da
hat er mich offensichtlich in allen
Punkten an gelogen weil gesagt wurde
nein wir werden hier nicht weiter
eskalieren das hat sich ja schon
abgezeichnet und deswegen auch auf die
Frage wer Vorbereitung wir haben ja ganz
verschiedene Szenarien genau uns
angeschaut vorbereitet wir wussten dass
es unterschiedlich Angriffe geben könnte
dass dieser Worst Case Szenario jetzt
Eintritt das ist einfach furchtbar so
deutlich muss man das sagen und deswegen
müssen wir jetzt alles dafür tun ich
komme zu meinem Anfangspunkt zurück aber
das sehe ich als unsere Verantwortung
als internationale Gemeinschaft Russland
jetzt ganz klar zu isolieren und
deutlich zu machen das akzeptieren wir
als Weltgemeinschaft nicht konnte sagen
Sie jetzt als Außenministerin mit diesen
Leuten im Kreml mit Putin und lavre hat
Diplomatie keine Chance mehr
diese Bezeichnung bald als Lügner weil
sie gelogen haben also ich finde man
muss Dinge auch klar aussprechen und
jetzt nicht mehr sprechen
aber Diplomatie kann nie zu Ende sein
weil dann werden internationale
Beziehungen zu Ende Diplomatie hat
offensichtlich in diesem Moment weil wir
es mit einem Regime zu tun haben was ich
nicht an internationale Regeln hält
nicht verhindern können dass Russland in
der Ukraine einmarschiert ist aber wir
sind in einer Situation wo es darum geht
Menschenleben zu schützen wir sind in
einer Situation wo wir offensichtlich im
Krieg sind das heißt über die Fragen ich
habe heute den eindringlichen Appell in
der OSZE gehalten dafür da wir haben
nach wie vorhin Beobachtermission der
OSZE da eindringlichen Appell deswegen
ja ich rede derzeit über Fernsehkameras
oder in der OSZE da sitzen ja russische
Vertreter sorgen sie für die Sicherheit
der oz-beobachtermission russland hat
selber entsandte dort dorthin geschickt
das heißt natürlich muss man in diesen
Formaten
weiterreden um Schlimmeres zu verhindern
aber mit der russischen Führung so wie
es derzeit ist und Sie werden und sie
setzen Hoffnung in die Sanktionen die
jetzt heute abend wahrscheinlich ja auch
noch von der EU geschlossen werden auch
die USA beide wird heute noch etwas
ankündigen reicht das angesichts der
vielen Milliarden über die Putin durch
Gas und Öleinnahmen gefüllte Staatsfonds
verfügen kann werden diese Sanktionen
dann das Stoppschild sein von dem sie
sprechen dass sie sagen bis hier und
nicht weiter haben sie da zutrauen
diese Sanktionspaket wird sicherlich
nicht dafür zu führen dass morgen alle
Truppen zurückgezogen werden aber
deswegen ist mir so wichtig deutlich zu
machen es geht jetzt in diesem Moment um
die Ukraine es geht aber für Putin um
Größeres darüber hinaus und deswegen
sagen wir mit diesem Sanktionspaket so
was ist nicht hinderbar das hat
Konsequenzen und zwar in den nächsten
Wochen in den nächsten Monaten wenn wir
jetzt Finanzströme stoppen dann macht
das für morgen und übermorgen erstmal
nichts mehr aus aber auf Dauer muss eine
Gesellschaft das tragen können wenn man
abgeschnitten ist vom internationalen
Finanzmarkt und da vielleicht auch
wichtiger Punkt was anders ist als 2014
wo ja die Menschen oder viele Menschen
in der in Russland zu diesem Krieg
relativ positiv eingestellt war das ist
jetzt anders 70 Prozent der Bevölkerung
russland will kein Krieg mit der Ukraine
auch was ich heute vom Botschafter in
Moskau gehört habe dass es da sehr sehr
viele kritische Stimmen gibt überhaupt
nicht diese
Begeisterung was da gemacht wird weil
hier für viele sind das ja Freunde
Bekannte Familien jetzt in der Ukraine
direkte angegriffen werden und das
deutlich zu machen auch mit Blick auf
die russische Gesellschaft die man nicht
gleichsetzen darf mit dem russischen
Regime das hat jetzt Konsequenzen dass
es für Putin auch spürbar ist
wirtschaftlich ökonomisch nicht sofort
das ist es nicht aber das ist ein
bisschen wenn wir jetzt wenn Sie jetzt
Ihre Frage andeutet gar keine Sanktionen
wäre ja die bringen ja sowieso nicht wir
haben wir sind ein Rechtsstaat zum Glück
und den verteidigen wir deswegen haben
wir in unserer Gesellschaft regeln wenn
man Regeln bricht hat das die Sequenzen
um deutlich zu machen es wie akzeptieren
das nicht da weiß man nicht ob derjenige
der Straftäter danach nicht nur eine
andere Straftat
begeht sondern man macht diese Regeln
auch zu Bestrafung das tun wir mit
diesen Sanktionspaket und wir machen
deutlich dass weitere Schritte weitere
massive Konsequenzen hätten wir müssen
langsam zum Ende kommen um Innenpolitik
geht es ja auch bei uns und es geht auch
um die Frage was kann man den Bürgern
zumuten man könnte sagen diese Tage
entscheiden auch über ihren Erfolg über
den Erfolg der neuen Bundesregierung der
Ampelkoalition und sie wissen auch ohne
russisches Gas können sie ihre
ehrgeizigen Klimaziele im Grunde nicht
erreichen die Energieversorgung
Deutschlands zu sichern ist eine ganz
wichtige Aufgabe für sie könnte das
heißen wenn es Schwierigkeiten gibt mit
den Gaslieferungen das wäre die nächste
Eskalation aus Moskau dann müssten die
Grünen bereit sein Kohle mehr zu
verbrennen oder Atomkraftwerke länger
laufen zu lassen
erst mal der Anfang Ihrer Frage über die
Beliebtheitswerte der deutschen
Bundesregierung auch der deutschen
Außenministerin mache ich mir gerade
überhaupt gar keine Gedanken sondern
mein ich habe sie gefragt ob sie auch
unsere Bevölkerung etwas zumuten und ob
sie unter diesen Bedingungen ihren Kurs
fortsetzen kann ja nur zu Beginn war es
innenpolitische Auswirkungen hat und das
ist mir wichtig deswegen ich möchte die
Haltung dieser Bundesregierung und auch
von mir deutlich machen dass wir in
einer Situation sind wo man ganz klar
sagen muss auf welcher Seite stehen wir
und sich nicht von innenpolitischen
Stimmung weil das haben wir auch erlebt
in zu vorherigen Zeiten ablenken lassen
darf das vorweg gesagt deswegen habe ich
heute in meiner ersten Erklärung dazu ja
auch sehr deutlich gesagt das wird auch
in Deutschland Konsequenzen haben das
wird auch ein wirtschaftlichen Preis in
Deutschland haben ja Energiepreise
werden steigen Herr Habeck hat ja schon
deutlich gemacht Jena wie Versorgung ist
gesichert aber natürlich werden die
Energiepreise steigen das war schon so
als ich gesagt hat Nord Stream 2 wird
Konsequenzen haben war schon im Dezember
dass damit gleich mal Energiepreise nach
oben gegangen sind aber diesen Preis
zahlen wir weil wenn wir jetzt die Augen
verschließen würden nicht handeln würden
mit Sanktionen dann hätte das für unser
Verständnis von internationalem Recht
ein noch viel höheren Preis und deswegen
treffen wir jetzt alle Maßnahmen und
Vorbereitung hatten sie angesprochen mit
Blick auf Gasreserven dass wir dafür
sorgen dass wir Gasreserven haben noch
so ein Punkt wo wir sagen das ist in der
Vergangenheit falsch gelaufen mit Blick
auf kohleabsicherung wir sind nach wie
vor in der Kohleverstromung drin da
müssen wir natürlich jetzt die
Vorkehrung treffen dass wenn Kohle nicht
mehr aus Russland käme dass wir sie von
anderen Orts bekommen und das macht der
Wirtschaftsminister gerade diese
Vorbereitung entsprechend zu treffen die
Regierung und sie als Außenministerin
sind noch keine 100 Tage im Amt jetzt
konfrontiert mit dieser Situation vor
gerade mal einem Monat war ja
Antrittsbesuch in Moskau zum Schluss
dieser Sendung wenn Sie auf diese
wenigen Wochen zurückschauen was was war
die größte Erkenntnis im Grunde jetzt
und wie bitter ist sie
sie ist
unglaublich bitter weil ich erlebt habe
das habe ich deswegen auch gesagt wie
ein eiskalt ins Gesicht gelungen wird
und zwar nicht nur ich der amerikanische
Präsident der französische Präsident der
deutsche Bundeskanzler was aber
unterstreicht wie wichtig eben das
Verständnis einer Werte geleiteten
Außenpolitik ist die in dieser Situation
deutlich macht wir werden unsere Werte
im Wettstreit darum geht es zwischen
einem autoritären
regierungsverständnis und liberalen
Werten verteidigen das war was nun
vielen Dank Frau bärbock vielen Dank
liebe zuschauen und Zuschauer für ihr
Interesse übrigens eine Sendung nach 2g+
Regeln das muss man in diesen Zeiten
auch immer noch sagen hier geht es jetzt
weiter direkt mit dem ZDF Spezial und
Matthias voll auf tschüss aus Berlin
ja wir kommen zurück beim zdf-spezialen
vor wenigen Minuten ist US-Präsident
beiden im Weißen Haus vor die Kameras
getreten wir hören mal kurz rein was er
gesagt hat
[Musik]
Putin ist der Adresse Putin hat sich
diesen Krieg gewählt und jetzt werden er
und sein Land die Konsequenzen tragen
ich autorisiere heute
zusätzliche starke Sanktionen und neue
Einschränkungen auf das was im
exportiert werden kann nach Russland
dass wir Tore Kosten für die russische
Wirtschaft bedeuten sofort und
langfristig wir haben absichtlich die
Sanktionen so gemacht dass sie einen
maximal langfristigen Einfluss auf
Russland haben einen minimalen Einfluss
auf Amerika und die Verbündeten die
Vereinigten Staaten machen das nicht
alleine
das sind starke Worte und starke
Ankündigungen ich bin jetzt verbunden
mit unserem Washington Korrespondenten
MRT Wissen guten Abend was war denn ihr
Eindruck von dieser Rede von Joe Biden
was lesen sie da raus
ja er hat schon sehr scharfe Sanktionen
angekündigt die tatsächlich noch etwas
darüber hinaus ging was wir erwartet
haben zumindest in drei der vier Punkte
von denen wir vorher immer gehört hatten
dass sie kommen würden der erste Punkt
ist dass die USA gegen fünf große Banken
Russlands Sanktionen verhängen werden
Sie daran hindern an internationalen
Märkten teilzunehmen Geld zu
organisieren für den russischen Staat
das betrifft die größten Banken des
Landes und deren ich sag mal Kapital
umfasst etwa eine Billion Dollar um mal
einen Eindruck zu bekommen die zweite
Sanktion richtet sich gegen Eliten und
ihre Familien wir haben noch keine
genauen Namen dazu bekommen wir wissen
das ja am Dienstag schon einmal
Sanktionen verhängt worden sind die
werden offenbar jetzt noch massiv
ausgedehnt der Präsident hat nicht
gesagt auf Wladimir Putin dann auch auf
dieser Liste stehen wird und die dritte
große Sanktion richtet sich gegen
staatliche Unternehmen die vor allen
Dingen im Hightech Bereich unterwegs
sind und wenn man dafür sorgen dass es
Exportkontrollen gibt für Hightech Güter
alles was Mikrochips Software oder
ähnliches mit amerikanischem oder
westlichen Know-how beinhaltet wird dann
unter diese Kontrolle gelegt und damit
will man etwa die Hälfte aller
russischen hightech-importe die
insgesamt Russland bekommt damit treffen
und im Grunde um abschneiden das heißt
im Umkehrschluss die rüstungsluft
Raumfahrt und seeindustrie die so sagte
Putin werde massiv getroffen werden
zusätzlich wird er auch noch weitere
Truppen entsenden und amerikanische
Waffen entsenden an die Ostflanke der
NATO weil er hat noch einmal wiederholt
dass Artikel 5 gilt wenn ein Angriff auf
ein Land der NATO erfolgen würde die
Ukraine zählt nicht dazu aber eins der
anderen Länder dann würde de facto
dieser Artikel 5 in Kraft treten und
dann werde man Putin sehr sehr klar
machen was dann passiert was er nicht
gesagt hat ist inwieweit
Energielieferungen tatsächlich betroffen
sein werden ich glaube das überlässt er
den europäischen Verbündeten weil es in
erster Linie um Gas und Öllieferungen an
Westeuropa geht da werden wir also im
Laufe des Abends wahrscheinlich noch
mehr dazu erfahren vielen Dank MRT
Wissen für diese Erläuterung man meint
doch auch eine gewisse Hilflosigkeit
auch bei der us-weltmacht da zu spüren
Dankeschön nach Washington
man hat ja außenministerinnen und zuvor
auch schon den Bundeskanzler den Ernst
der Lage angesehen Krieg in Europa
Überfall auf einen unabhängigen Staat
das schien unvorstellbar seit Ende des
Kalten Krieges jetzt ist es bedrohliche
Wirklichkeit es hat bereits dutzende
Opfer gegeben Soldaten und Zivilisten
genaue Zahlen kennt niemand wir haben
hier immer einen Blick auf die
Bildsignale die uns vorlegen wir sammeln
alles an Informationen was verfügbar ist
und bringen das sofort in diese Sendung
um uns aber alle noch mal auf den
aktuellsten Stand zu bringen hat mein
Kollege Gerd Anhalt zusammengefasst was
wir wissen was geschehen ist an diesem
ersten Tag des Krieges
wie ein Unwetter am östlichen Horizont
zieht der Krieg hinter harkev auf 40 km
vor der russischen Grenze ungläubig und
verwirrt die Reaktionen der Augenzeugen
was war das wo kam das her
und schon bald befinden sich die
Bewohner der Millionenstadt mitten im
Krieg
das war der schlimmste Sonnenaufgang
meines Lebens sagt die junge Frau ich
wachte um 5 Uhr auf weil geschossen
wurde rannte auf den Balkon da wurde mir
klar das war kein Feuerwerk
da stieg schon unweit von harkeeferner
Rauchsäule über dem Luftwaffenstützpunkt
tschuhjew auf den die Russen gleich
unter Feuer nahmen um die Luft Abwehr
auszuschalten
und selbst 800 Kilometer westlich in der
Hauptstadt Kiew begann der Tag mit
Sirenen Geheule und der ukrainische
Präsident selenski wandte sich mit einer
offenbar hast dich aufgezeichneten
smartphone-botschaft an sein Volk
Explosionen werden aus vielen Städten
der Ukraine gemeldet wir führen hier mit
das Kriegsrecht ein vor einer Minute
habe ich mit Präsident beiden gesprochen
die Amerikaner bemühen sich um
internationale Unterstützung
während von der Krim her die ersten
Militärkonvois Richtung Westen rollten
formierten sich im Hinterland immer neue
Kolonnen von Lkw und Panzern zum größten
Truppen Einmarsch seit dem Zweiten
Weltkrieg
ihre Angriffe gelten nur militärischen
Zielen behaupten die russischen
Strategen aber die ersten Bilder aus der
Ostukraine zeigten nicht nur zerstörte
Infrastruktur hier soll es sich um den
Flughafen von Mario Paul handeln
sondern auch getroffene Wohnanlagen und
Ziele ohne erkennbaren militärcharakter
[Musik]
Kiews Verteidigungsminister rief alle
einsatzfähigen Landsleute auf sich
umgehend bei der Truppe zu melden
jeder der eine Waffe halten kann soll
sich bei den Streitkräften einfinden wir
haben das Verfahren vereinfacht jedem
Patrioten der seinen Pass vorzeigt wird
ein Gewehr ausgehändigt
und auch durch die selbst ernannten
Volksrepubliken weht der Ruf der
Mobilmachung freiwillige sammeln sich in
Donezk um für Russland und ihr
Separatisten Gebiet zu kämpfen dass dies
ein Krieg gegen ihre Landsleute ist
scheint ihnen gleichgültig
und bald essen wir dann in Kiew Hühnchen
kiewa Art scherzt die Gattin zum
Abschied
zur gleichen Zeit bricht in Kiew der
Verkehr zusammen als habe die ganze
Stadt nur noch ein Ziel schnell weg von
hier in Sicherheit
ich bin eigentlich aus with Lemberg und
ich bin ein Patriot ich bringe nur meine
Kinder weg und dann komme ich wieder um
zu kämpfen
jedoch sind die Straßen verstopft und
die Mitfahrgelegenheiten rar Taxidienste
und Mitfahrzentrale kaum zu erreichen
und komplett ausgebucht die Preise haben
sich über Nacht vervielfacht
ich will zu meinen Eltern die wohnen auf
dem Lande da ist es sicherer
auf dem Luftweg gibt es jedenfalls kein
Entkommen der Flughafen ist lahmgelegt
auch hier wurde am Morgen Geschützfeuer
vernommen und den Luftraum über der
Ukraine meiden die meisten Fluglinien
schon seit Tagen
unser Flug wurde wegen des
Kriegsausbruchs abgesagt und nun erklärt
uns keiner was passiert und was wir tun
sollen keiner gibt uns eine Antwort und
wir wissen nicht wie es nun weitergehen
soll
ein ganzes Land so scheint es erwachte
an der Schwelle zur Panik so deutlich
die Anzeichen waren so bedrohlich die
Kulisse dass es wirklich so weit kommen
würde dass glaubten bis heute morgen nur
die Pessimisten
ich fühle Panik Angst und Aufregung ich
weiß nicht wen ich um Hilfe bitten soll
es ist fürchterlich wir haben nicht
daran geglaubt bis wir dann die
Explosionen gehört haben und die Panik
ausbrach ich will meine Eltern
verabschieden die bringen sich in
Sicherheit
die Hauptstädter sollen sich in den
Luftschutzkellern aus der Zeit des
Kalten Krieges in Sicherheit bringen
Stahltüren und der Dicke Beton halten
Artilleriebeschuss und Luftangriffen
stand heißt es
alle Bürger sind informiert über die
Zugänge zu unseren Schutzräumen und
können dort Zuflucht suchen wer nicht in
der kritischen Infrastruktur arbeitet
der soll zu Hause bleiben und sich
bereithalten verfolgen Sie die
Nachrichten und bleiben Sie ruhig
dass die Angst vor einem Angriff auf die
drei Millionen Metropole nicht
unbegründet ist bewies ein
Raketeneinschlag der die Anwohner der
Geschäftsstraße im Süden der Stadt am
Vormittag aufschreckte gezielter
Beschuss oder doch ein Irrläufer
es gab keinen Rauch und keinen Geruch
ich wusste nicht was passiert ist ich
bin fassungslos da waren auch Passanten
mit Einkaufstaschen und Kinder unterwegs
bevor er den Befehl zum Angriff auf die
Ukraine gab legte Kremlchef Putin
gestern in Moskau noch einen Kranz am
Grab des unbekannten Soldaten nieder es
war der sogenannte Tag der Vaterlands
Beschützer der üblicherweise mit
Schokolade und viel Wodka gefeiert wird
und an dem schon die Kleinsten frohgemut
auf den Dienst mit der Waffe eingestimmt
werden und als dieser Tag zu Ende ging
setzte der Präsident seine Armeen in
Bewegung
wie schon zuvor am Schreibtisch neben
seinen Telefonen erklärte er dass er den
bedrängten Republiken luchans und Don
jetzt beistehen wolle die sind seit acht
Jahren der Folter und dem Völkermord des
Regimes in Kiew ausgesetzt unser Ziel
ist nicht die Besetzung der Ukraine
sondern nur ihre Entnazifizierung und
Entmilitarisierung behauptet er nicht
und an die Adresse des Westens dem er am
vergangenen Wochenende mit einem großen
raketenmanöver gezeigt hatte wie ernst
es ihm ist hatte er gestern auch noch
eine Warnung
sollte sich da jemand einmischen wollen
und uns gar bedrohen dann wird unsere
Antwort unmittelbar erfolgen und zu
Konsequenzen führen die einmalig sind in
der Geschichte
im Laufe des Tages lehrten sich dann die
Straßen der Innenstadt von Kiew und eine
fast gespenstische Ruhe breitete sich
aus bis dann die ersten feindlichen
Hubschrauber über den Wohngebieten
kreisten da meldeten die
Sicherheitsbehörden aus dem ganzen Land
schon mehr als 200 russische Angriffe
selbst ganz im Westen des Landes im
alten Lemberg nahe der polnischen Grenze
trieben Angst und Unsicherheit die
Menschen zu den Geldautomaten manche
wollten ihr Erspartes retten andere
brauchten es für die Flucht
und bei mir im Studio begrüße ich Egon
Rams er ist ehemaliger Bundeswehr
general und war bis zu seinem
Ausscheiden einer der ranghöchsten
deutschen Soldaten bei der NATO guten
Abend
als sie heute morgen von den massiven
Angriffen Russlands ja eben nicht nur
auf das Don Bass im Osten sondern auf
die ganze Ukraine erfahren haben was
haben sie da gedacht ich war sehr
überrascht ich war einfach überrascht
darüber dass Putin offensichtlich rund
um die Ukraine rum die Angriffe befohlen
hat und damit aus allen Bereichen Süden
Osten Norden möglicherweise aus dem
westlichen Bereich über Transnistrien
Angriff erfolgen die Ukraine ist ja nun
mal kein NATO-Mitglied das löst also
diese Angriff auch kein Bündnisfall aus
der Nato-Generalsekretär hat heute
betont man werde etwas defensives tun
wie kann man das verstehen Putin von
Leipzig die Ukraine ein und der Westen
schaut zu
ja wir sind in dieser Situation die NATO
ist ein Verteidigungsbündnis seit 1949
hat bisher nie jemand angegriffen das
ist auch nach wie vor nicht die Absicht
dabei und aus diesem Grunde kann die
NATO tatsächlich nur das machen was
möglich ist um ihre eigenen
Mitgliedstaaten von Estland bis nach
Bulgarien entsprechend zu schützen durch
Truppenverstärkung und dergleichen mehr
ist aber auch bezeichnet und das muss
noch erfolgen dass verschiedene
Regierungen der NATO-Staaten nach
Artikel 4 die entsprechenden ich sagte
mal Beratung Konsultationen angefordert
haben und da muss man sehen wie das
ausgeht ja vor allem die baltischen
Staaten und Polen die machen sich
natürlich jetzt Sorgen nach diesem
Angriff von Russland die sind
NATO-Staaten die NATO verlagert mehr
Soldaten dorthin besteht die Gefahr dass
die NATO doch noch reingezogen wird in
diesen Konflikt also ich glaube das
nicht aber man kann solche Dinge nicht
ausschließen das Spiel manchmal zu viel
eine Rolle dabei das beispielsweise
russische Truppen irgendwo im Bereich
Rumänien oder Bulgarien Grenzen
überschreiten und dann könnte es zu
Gefechten kommen und dann muss man die
Besonnenheit der Militär Führer vor Ort
und auch der politischen Führung in der
NATO halt eben im Auge behalten dabei
aber ich denke dass der Generalsekretär
Stoltenberg und die nachgeordneten
militärischen Führer ihre Soldaten
zumindest in den Staaten die eine
gemeinsame Grenzen mit der Ukraine und
Weißrussland haben entsprechend darauf
vorbereitet haben dass man hier höchste
Vorsicht walten lässt damit man nicht in
einen Krieg rein schlendert ich würde
sie noch mal gerne Fragen aus
militärischer Sicht was erwarten Sie für
den nächsten Tage kann die ukrainische
Armee ernsthaft Widerstand leisten also
nach meiner bisherigen Beurteilung war
das so dass ich gesagt habe ja weil die
ukrainische Armee die wir heute haben
ist nicht mehr dieses Jahr 2014 die war
desolat und schwach schlecht ausgebildet
das hat sich geändert und ich bin etwas
überrascht dass wir in den Darstellungen
die wir heute bekommen im Prinzip
überhaupt keine oder nur sehr wenige
Nachrichten über Reaktionen oder
Handlungen der ukrainische Streitkräfte
bekommen weil wir kriegen bisher nur die
Meldung die Russen sind weiter
vorgerückt sie sind bisher mobil
gekommen oder dergleichen Dinge mehr sie
haben die Flugplätze beschossen und zum
Teil unbrauchbar gemacht das ist so ein
enthauptungsschlag den man gemacht hat
um auch diese Art und Weise die
ukrainische Luftwaffe von vornherein
Schach mal zu setzen ja und wenn unsere
Ziele offensichtlich auch Kiew
einzunehmen oder zumindest die Regierung
da rauszuholen also ich war bei dem
Beitrag den wir gerade gesehen haben
sehr überrascht über die russischen
Kampfhubschrauber und russischen
Transporthubschrauber die sich praktisch
im Luftraum Kiew bewegt haben das hätte
ich mir in den letzten Tagen noch nicht
so vorstellen können herzlichen Dank für
das Gespräch Herz
und noch ein Hinweis an dieser Stelle
die für heute Abend geplante Sendung
kölle Alaaf die Mädchensitzung fällt
aufgrund der aktuellen Ereignisse aus
die Karnevalssitzung steht in der ZDF
Mediathek zum abrufbereit
die Staats- und Regierungschefs der EU
treffen sich in diesen Stunden in
Brüssel um über Reaktionen zu beraten an
der geleneck unsere Korrespondentin
beobachtet das Anne was ist da heute zu
erwarten es hieß ja immer harte
Sanktionen gegen Russland seien
vorbereitet wie könnten die Aussehen ja
tatsächlich gibt es ein ganzes
Sanktionspaket über das die Staats- und
Regierungschefs in den letzten Wochen
schon verhandelt haben und was
eigentlich fertig in der Schublade liegt
darin in erster Linie eine Liste
russischer Banken die sich künftig kein
Geld mehr auf westlichen Kapitalmärkten
Märkten leihen können sollen die keine
Geschäfte mehr mit dem Westen machen
können allerdings kein Ausschluss vom
Bezahlsystem Swift da haben die Europäer
doch noch ein bisschen Sorge dass sie
sich selbst damit auch zu sehr schaden
könnten dann als zweite Komponente des
Sanktionspaket Export Stopps für
Technologie die die russische Wirtschaft
dringend braucht darunter zum Beispiel
fördertechnologie für den Gas und Öl für
die Gas und Ölförderung oder auch für
die Luftfahrttechnik und die Raumfahrt
und der dritte Punkt der Sanktionen sind
die Ausweitung von
einreisebeschränkungen für eine ganze
Kaste rund um den Präsidenten Wladimir
Putin wie zu hören war aus der
EU-Kommission die Hoffnung ist dass man
mit diesen Sanktionen sozusagen den
inneren Kreis um Wladimir Putin trifft
dass die unzufrieden werden und
möglicherweise darauf einwirken dass
Putin seine Politik ändert ob das klappt
wird man dann in den nächsten Wochen
sehen ja vielen Dank Anne sie werden das
weiter in den Abend über für uns im
Blick haben für den Moment vielen Dank
nach Brüssel
das Hoffen auf einer diplomatische
Lösung auf ein russisches Einlenken fast
nirgends war es so groß wie in
Deutschland so ist die deutsche Politik
vielleicht besonders hart auf dem Boden
der Realität gelandet Deutschland sei
fassungslos aber nicht hilflos hat
Außenministerin bärbock gesagt es war
also ein besonderer Tag in Berlin
Politik im krisenmodus Tagung des
sicherheitskabinetts am Sonntag wird der
Bundestag zusammentreten es ist Krieg im
Europa
Bundeskanzler Scholz hat sich am Abend
in einer Ansprache an die Bevölkerung
Gewand der sagte wörtlich wir sind
entschlossen und Handeln geschlossen
darin liegt unsere Stärke als freie
Demokratien putin wird nicht gewinnen
es werden stündlich mehr die rund ums
Brandenburger Tor gegen den russischen
Angriff auf die Ukraine demonstrieren
wie gefährlich die Bundesregierung die
Situation einschätzt lässt sich schon
allein daran messen dass sich der
Bundeskanzler mit einer Fernsehansprache
an die Nation wendet
das ist ein Überfall auf ein
unabhängiges souveränes Land es durch
nichts und durch niemanden
zurechtfertigen es ist der Versuch
Grenzen innerhalb Europas gewaltsam zu
verschieben ja vielleicht ein ganzes
Land von der Weltkarte zu tilgen wer
nach Unterschieden zwischen den
Regierungsparteien sucht wird heute
keine finden SPD FDP und Grüne zeigen
sich entschlossen wenn in denen klar
Ross und Reiter es war immer ein
Albtraum dass es wieder zu Krieg in
Europa kommen könnte dieser Albtraum ist
jetzt traurige Realität geworden
dafür trägt der Kreml dafür trägt
Vladimir Putin die Verantwortung er hat
sich als ein Lügner selbst entlarvt die
Sanktionen gegen Russland werden wohl
deutlich stärker ausfallen als bislang
bekannt war ein Sanktionspaket dass die
russische Wirtschaft abkoppeln wird vom
industriellen Vorsprung und geschehen
das vermögens- und Finanzwerte
attackieren wird und einfrieren wird und
die zu den Zugang zu den europäischen
und amerikanischen Märkten deutlich
beschränken wird die Energieversorgung
in Deutschland sei trotz großer
Abhängigkeiten von Russland vorerst
gesichert schickt Habeck noch hinterher
die äußere Ruhe im Regierungsviertel
täuscht hinter verschlossenen Türen
Tagen das krisenkabinett Ausschüsse und
Fraktionen die Union sonst gerne
kritisch gegenüber der Koalition stellt
sich in der Krise hinter Regierung wir
werden deswegen die Bundesregierung bei
ihren Bemühungen diesen Konflikte
einzudämmen auch in ihren allen
diplomatischen Bemühungen nach Kräften
unterstützen wie aber sieht es bei den
Parteien aus die eine nicht unerhebliche
Zahl von Russland Freunden beherbergen
die AFD verurteilt zwar den Einmarsch
sieht aber auch die Bundesregierung in
der Verantwortung mit feministischer
Außenpolitik erreicht man eben keine
Konfliktlösung und auch mit viel Geld in
andere Staaten tragen eben auch nicht
also hier muss es im Prinzip auch die
Sicherheitsinteressen aller europäischen
Länder berücksichtigt werden im übrigen
auch Russlands die Linkspartei klingt ja
deutlich anders das ist ganz klar ohne
jede Relativierung ein
völkerrechtswidriger Angriffskrieg den
Präsident Putin zu verantworten hat und
während die Welt geschockt nach Osten
schaut haben sich die Jecken in Köln die
Laune nicht verderben lassen es bedurfte
erst eines Eingreifens des
Ministerpräsidenten das wenigstens
Rosenmontagszug abgesagt wird Berlin
dagegen zeigt Solidarität und lässt auch
heute Abend das Brandenburger Tor in den
Farben der ukrainischen Flagge
erstrahlen
und in Berlin begrüße ich den
Vorsitzenden des Auswärtigen Ausschusses
im Bundestag Michael Roth guten Abend
hallo Herr fornhoff von einem guten
Abend möchte ich lieber nicht sprechen
ja da haben sie allerdings recht es ist
kein guter Tag viele Menschen in
Deutschland sind in tiefer Sorge teilen
Sie die
Teile ich denn wir erleben hier nicht
nur einen von Putin angezettelten Krieg
gegen die Ukraine sondern das ist ein
Angriff auf das Europa der Freiheit und
der Demokratie denn viel mehr Angst vor
Soldaten und Soldaten der NATO hat der
Aggressor Putin Angst vor unseren Werten
und vor diesen Werten will er sich
abkoppeln und er
verneint das Existenzrecht von
souveränen freien Staaten wie der
Ukraine aber auch das Existenzrecht
anderer osteuropäischer Staaten die mal
aus der Sowjetunion hervorgegangen sind
ein offener Angriffskrieg das war in
Europa jahrzehntelang nicht denkbar was
verändert das für ganz Europa und auch
für Deutschland
wir haben uns über viele Jahre hinweg
bemüht die Friedensdividende die wir
erwarteten nach dem Fall der Mauer nach
dem Zusammenbruch der kommunistischen
Diktatur zu einer europäischen
sicherheitsordnung aufzubauen
weiterzuentwickeln die alle mit
einbezieht und davon werden wir uns
vorerst verabschieden können es wird
eine Sicherheitsarchitektur geben aber
ohne Riss Russland mit dem westlichen
Balkan mit den anderen Staaten des
östlichen Europas aber ich sehe derzeit
mit Putin Russland keine Chance auf
Verständigung und auf friedliche
Koexistenz und das wird uns auf zu
großer Wachsamkeit verpflichten harte
Wirtschaftssanktionen hat Putin sicher
erwartet sind wir nicht in Wirklichkeit
ziemlich hilflos gegenüber diesem
russischen Angriffskrieg wir sind
überhaupt nicht hilflos wir als
freiheitliche Demokratien sollten uns
das auch nicht einreden lassen natürlich
agieren wir anders als ein
Aggressor als ein autoritärer Herrscher
der kein Problem mehr mit hat Soldaten
und Soldaten in einen Krieg zu schicken
und Menschenleben auf dem Gewissen zu
haben die Sanktionen die wir jetzt in
kürzester Zeit auf den Weg gebracht
haben setzen ein klares Stoppschild und
was mich wütend macht ist dass wir das
Umfeld von Putin ja nach wie vor haben
dass die Privilegien des freien Europas
zu genießen beabsichtigt und
gleichzeitig einen Krieg unterstützt und
hier müssen wir ansetzen diejenigen die
ihre Kinder auf Privatschulen in Europa
bringen die Luxuswohnungen Berlin oder
London kaufen du die ihr Geld in die
Schweiz transferieren die müssen
bestraft werden von denen muss Druck auf
Putin ausgeübt werden und dann werden
wir insgesamt mit diesen Sanktionen die
Wirtschaft und das wirtschaftliche Leben
von Russland sanktionieren und bestrafen
und isolieren aber wichtig ist mir auch
das Signal wir wollen nicht die
russische Gesellschaft bestrafen was
mich hoffnungsvoll stimmt dass wir heute
Abend auch Proteste erlebt haben in
Sankt Peter Hamburg gegen diesen Krieg
die russische Bevölkerung ist nicht
einverstanden mit dieser Aggression aber
putin ist ein Diktator unersetzt das
gnadenlos durch vielen Dank für das
Gespräch Michael Roth
und gerade wird aus dem Pentagon
gemeldet dass die USA 7000 zusätzliche
Soldaten nach Deutschland schicken und
in Berlin begrüße ich jetzt den
Botschafter der Ukraine in Deutschland
andere Melnik für Sie und Ihr Land ist
das ein schwarzer Tag auch für den
Frieden in Europa russland hat von drei
Seiten angegriffen russische Truppen auf
einem Flugplatz kurz vor Kiew wieder
dramatisch ist die Lage Herr Botschafter
die Lage ist in der Tat sehr schwierig
aber es ist noch nicht zu spät uns
Ukrainer der Zivilbevölkerung zu helfen
wir haben heute im Laufe des Tages
gehört dass es uns nur wenige Stunden
bleiben und zwar von den
Regierungsmitgliedern und deswegen macht
es auch keinen Sinn und jetzt zu helfen
in dem Sinne dass man einen
wirtschafts-paket eine Rettungspaket auf
den Weg bringen dass man auch uns mit
Schuss Ausrüstung mit defensiv Waffen
ausstattet wir glauben es es wäre nicht
fair die Ukraine zu früh aufzugeben man
darf für den Willen und den kampfgeister
unsere Armee aber auch der Menschen im
Lande unterschätzen und deswegen möchte
ich an die deutsche Öffentlichkeit heute
wiederholten appellieren und sie alle
bitten unsere Freunde helfen Sie uns die
Ampel der Regierung zu überzeugen dass
es ein ein falscher Weg wäre uns Ukraine
einfach im zu lassen einheitlich
verurteilt ja der Westen den russischen
Überfall auf ihr Land gerade berät die
EU über weitreichende Sanktionen gegen
Russland wir haben auch den
US-Präsidenten gehört reicht ihnen das
oder muss der Westen mehr tun und wenn
dann was
was die Sanktionen betrifft natürlich
begrüßen wir diesen Schritt aber ich
habe heute mit
regierungsvertreten mit den
Regierungsmitgliedern gesprochen hier in
Berlin und nach meiner Frage ob sie
selbst glauben dass diese Sanktionen
jetzt das Verhalten von Putin verändern
können und ob er jetzt diesen Kriege
kurzfristige stoppen kann dann war die
Antwort nein und das heißt dass dieser
Sanktionen doch nicht ausreichend sind
es fehlen wichtige Teile zum Beispiel
Ausschuss Ausschlüsse Russlands vom
Swift Zahlungssystem das im barco für
Energie Rohstoffe aus Russland wurde
auch nicht eingeführte weil Deutschland
dass ich quer gestellt hatte das heißt
auch da gibt es immer noch viel Luft
nach oben aber es geht auch darum dass
man jetzt der Ukraine unter die Arme
greift mit
Wirtschaftshilfe mit scherehilfe die wir
brauchen aber auch damit dass unsere
Armee gestärkt wird wir brauchen
Kraftstoff wir brauchen so vieles mehr
was die Deutschen natürlich wissen was
benötigt wird und es wäre einfach nicht
fair die Ukraine zu sagen dass man
solidarisch an der Seite des
ukrainischen Volkes States einerseits
und auf der anderen Seite einfache uns
aufzugeben
sie wünschen sich da Unterstützung man
sollte der Ukraine unter die Arme
greifen was genau erhoffen sie sich von
der Bundesregierung mit Bitte um kurzer
Antwort ja wir hoffen dass die
Bundesregierung sich einfach bemüht was
zu tun denn heute habe ich gar keine
Bereitschaften gespürte dass man
überhaupt fähige und und willensäste uns
zu helfen weil man sagt ja in der
nächsten Stunden werden Fallschirmjäger
landen an diesem Flughafen
in der Nähe von von Kiefer und es wird
einen regime change geben da sind die
Worte der deutschen Bundesregierung und
wir glauben dass das wäre jetzt einfach
nicht fair uns da unserem Schicksal zu
überlassen vielen Dank Herr Botschafter
für das Gespräch vielen Dank
es gibt viel zu reden an diesem ersten
Kriegstag Maybrit Illner hat eine
spannende Gesprächsrunde zusammen
deshalb gebe ich jetzt ab nach Berlin
über aktuelle Entwicklungen halten wir
Sie auf dem Laufenden Maybrit Illner
danke Matthias vornhoff und einen guten
Abend hier aus Berlin Kriege in Europa
beginnen selten an einem Mittwoch sagt
der Russlands EU-Botschafter dieser Satz
zeigt den ganzen Zynismus der russischen
Regierung denn heute ist Donnerstag und
heute hat Russland einen Krieg begonnen
wladimir Putin hat die Ukraine
überfallen bis zuletzt worden ist viele
nicht glauben auch die Menschen in der
Ukraine nicht Europa scheckt Ihnen
solidaritätsadressen was kann es sonst
noch tun auch das eine Frage über die
wir heute reden wollen ich begrüße im
Studio den SPD-Vorsitzenden Lars
Klingbeil gut dass sie heute bei uns
sind Melanie Ammann
Hauptstadtstudio des Spiegel und wir
sind dankbar dafür dass Erich Fahrt bei
uns ist Brigade general ade und lange
Berater der Bundeskanzlerin Angela
Merkel in allen Fragen der Verteidigung
und begrüßen möchte ich ganz zu Beginn
mit einer ersten Frage gleich startend
Marina weißband Bündnis grüne
Politikerin und aus Münster zugeschaltet
und in der Ukraine geboren Marina weiß
man ihre Freunde ihre Familie wie geht
es Ihnen
ich bin mit meiner Familie heute seit 5
Uhr morgens im Kontakt es geht den
Menschen sehr verschieden meine Familie
scheint es im Moment gut zu gehen sie
sind zu Hause sie sagen aus der Stadt
heraus kommt man gerade nicht wirklich
aber man wisst auch gar nicht wohin man
fahren soll man versucht sich
einzudecken mit Lebensmitteln mit Benzin
mit allem was über die nächste Zeit
hilft und man hängt vor den Nachrichten
andere Menschen reagieren panischer wir
wissen auch von Bekannten die den ganzen
Vormittag mit ihren Kindern in den mit
rohschichten verbracht haben um nicht
von Explosionen getroffen zu werden wir
wissen von Dörfern in der Nähe der
belarussischen Grenze wo Eltern unter so
heftigem Beschuss lagen dass sie in den
Kellern buchstäblich über ihren Kindern
gelegen haben also die Situation stellt
sich für Menschen verschieden da es gibt
gerade viele Bemühungen also junge
Männer schreiben sich ein in den Dienst
und man kann sich nicht nur für die
Front freiwillig melden sondern es
werden in Kiew auch Nachbarschaft Boden
aufgestellt die dann dass sie jeweils
eigene Viertel verteidigen und selbst da
werden teilweise Gräben gegraben das
heißt wenn Putin mit einer schnellen
Kapitulation der Ukraine rechnet dann
hat er glaube ich die Rechnung ohne das
ukrainische Volk gemacht wohin können
die Menschen fliehen Marina weiß baden
können Sie nach Polen fliehen nach
Rumänien
im Moment sagt man der leichteste Weg
sei die südöstliche Grenze wo es
Anlaufstellen für Flüchtlinge gibt es
ist allerdings ein bisschen schwer
dorthin zu kommen weil es sich natürlich
auf den Straßen staut
ich weiß es nicht genau weil in meinem
unmittelbaren Bekanntenkreis niemand die
Ukraine verlässt man will die Ukraine
auch nicht verlassen weil es genau darum
geht das eigene demokratische
unabhängige Land zu verteidigen damit
man eben ein Land hat in dass man
zurückgehen kann deswegen alle
flüchtlingsgeschichten kenne ich auch
nur secondhand wird Putin diesen Krieg
beenden bevor seine Truppen in der
Hauptstadt Kiew steht
ich denke Putins ziel ist es eine pro
russische Regierung einzusetzen und zu
zeigen dass ein demokratisches Land
neben Russland nicht bestehen kann
und er wird das versuchen zu tun das
werden die Ukraine aber nicht zulassen
deswegen sehe ich kein baldiges Ende
dieses Konflikts bei uns ist Erich Fahrt
Brigade general ade Herr fragt was Sie
bisher über diesen russischen Angriff
Wissen der ja von drei Seiten kamen und
eine Invasion ist folgt das einem
Lehrbuch einem Lehrplan also ich denke
dieser Angriff ist ja ein konzentrischer
Angriff von mehreren Seiten aus einer
militärstrategischen Situationen die den
Ukrainern im Grunde um keinen Spielraum
lässt militärisch von Süden von Norden
von Osten er hat die Möglichkeit aus dem
Belarus Frau Weißmann hat das ja
angesprochen sehr schnell beiderseits
des jepper auf Kiew vorzustoßen er ist
ja wahrscheinlich mit luftlandekräften
und Spezialkräften schon in dem Raum
er greift gleichzeitig von der Krim aus
an in Richtung von Odessa da ist eine
sehr starke russische russische
sprachige Community auch und es zeichnet
sich auch ab dass er aus dem dombas eine
Landverbindung sucht in Richtung Krim
das sind die Optionen die Ostukraine
denke ich mal wird er sehr schnell mit
bodenkampftruppen besetzen es läuft
klassisch ab mit Raketenangriffen vorweg
Artillerie Luftwaffe hat schon die
Luftherrschaft erreicht innerhalb von
Stunden und die große Frage ist ob er
tatsächlich die gesamte Ukraine auf
Dauer besetzt ich halte das für
unwahrscheinlich vor allen Dingen der
Westteil der Ukraine will mit Russland
eigentlich nicht so viel am Hut haben es
würde auch sehr stark an das an die
nato-grenze Grenzen so dass ich
insgesamt glaube ja Kiew schon er wird
Kiew nehmen müssen er wird eine
provisorische Regierung einsetzen und
vielleicht dann aus der Westukraine und
aus Kirche hinaus ziehen äh aber ich
denke die Schwarzmeerküste Krim auch die
Landverbindung in den dombas und damit
die Verbindung auch nach transnistin
Moldawien wo er auch so ein
frozen-konflikt geschaffen hat das wird
erhalten das ist einfach strategisch
wichtig und dann haben wir eine Ukraine
als rumstaat mit einer
Marionettenregierung ich glaube mal wenn
ich das kurz zusammenfasse das ist ein
Ziel das ist ein Ziel das ist eine
Marionettenregierung in Putin in Kiew
gibt Entschuldigung wir Fragen gleich
noch mal Marina Weißmann in Münster das
ukrainische Militär zu zerstören eine
Marionettenregierung einzusetzen in Kiew
glauben sie wird Putin bevor er diese
beiden Kriegsziele erreicht hat aufhören
dieses Land zu bombardieren
auf keinen Fall also ich denke nicht ich
denke sogar dass er noch weitergehen
wird ich denke das ist ein Zwischenziel
aber wenn wir seine Rede hören seinen
Aufsatz von 2001 hören und auch die
Ankündigung hören die er heute Nacht
gegeben hat er hat heute Nacht viele
widerliche Lügen gesagt aber er hat
einen unwillkürlich waren Satz gesagt er
hat gesagt der russische Staat kann
nicht existieren neben einer modernen
Ukraine und damit hat er unwillkürlich
seine Motivationslage verraten dieser
Konflikt begann 2014 als es in der
Ukraine eine erfolgreiche pro
demokratische Revolution gab und Putin
hat von nichts mehr Angst als das sein
eigenes Volk sich mit dieser Idee der
Demokratie ansteckt und seine eigene
klettokratie beendet und deswegen
kämpft er nicht nur um das russische
Reich wieder aufzubauen das russische
Imperium und das geht weit über die
Ukraine hinaus da sind eben auch
nat privaten betroffen da sind auch
EU-Staaten betroffen sondern er kämpft
gegen die Demokratie an sich die hat er
versucht zu destabilisieren in den USA
und in Europa und in der Ukraine er kann
nicht zulassen dass neben ihm ein
erfolgreicher moderner demokratischer
Staat prosperiert und das alles so ein
Sorgen machen war dann die deutsche
Regierung war dann diese ampelregierung
zu zögerlich zu zurückhaltend manche
sagen zufolge
ich halte die Reaktionen für zu
zurückhaltend ich war jetzt positiv
überrascht als dann die Anerkennung
dieser beiden Separatisten Gebiete
erfolgte dass dann tatsächlich auch
klare Worte und auch klare Sanktionen
mit Nord Stream 2 folgten und ich höre
jetzt aus den Parteien wirklich klare
und scharfe Worte ich würde mir trotzdem
wünschen dass die sanktionspakete die
heute beschlossen wurden beschlossen
werden vorgestern gezündet worden wären
vielleicht wäre uns das dann erspart
geblieben und ich weiß auch nicht warum
man das nach und nach aufbaut ich glaube
ein schnelles abschrecken der Leute die
Putin dieser Handlungen ermöglichen ist
im Moment die einzige Chance eine
unabhängige Ukraine zu wahren die wir
noch haben laskingball ist bei uns im
Studio Herr klingt weil die Ukrainer
wehren sich jetzt mit Waffen sie wären
sich irgendwann vielleicht auch ohne
Waffen gegen die russischen Panzer
werden wir zuschauen bis dieser
Widerstand gebrochen ist müssen wir dann
nebensitzen zuschauen wir schauen ja
nicht zu wenn ich das mal zusammenfasse
dann hat Deutschland in den letzten acht
Jahren als größtes Land neben den USA
wirtschaftliche Hilfen gegeben wir haben
die Resilienz der Ukraine gestärkt wir
haben also wir haben die Emotionalität
haben wir haben in den letzten Wochen
gerade erlebt Olaf Scholz an der Spitze
Anna Lena baerbock die gesamte
Bundesregierung dass wir ich glaube so
geschlossen wie lange nicht mehr mit den
USA mit den anderen EU-Staaten politisch
unser Gewicht in die Waagschale geworfen
haben und heute Abend werden in Brüssel
Sanktionen beschlossen die auch uns
wirtschaftlich hart treffen also wir
nehmen in Kauf sehr bewusst auch eigene
ökonomische Konsequenzen weil wir eben
geschlossen handeln und weil wir jetzt
auch sagen die russische Regierung
rund um Putin werden das zu spüren
bekommen also man darf die Europäische
Union und das transatlantische
Verhältnis dann nicht unterschätzen die
Ukraine fühlt sich aber nicht
unterstützt wir haben vom ukrainischen
Botschafter vor Tagen noch gehört dass
es Verrat der deutschen sei am
ukrainischen Volk glauben Sie dass das
schnell genug geschehen kann sind wir
mit Sanktionen nicht dann wirklich auch
bei einem Mittel das ja erst auf die
Zeit wirkt also es fällt natürlich
schwer zu argumentieren in einer Phase
und Marina weißband hat das gerade
eindrucksvoll beschrieben wo das Land
angegriffen wird wo dort Menschen
verfolgt werden wo dort Panzer durch die
straßenrollen und ich glaube auch hier
in Deutschland wird heute in vielen
Wohnzimmern erstmals seit Jahren wieder
über Krieg geredet über Krieg mitten in
Europa aber trotzdem hat die
Bundesregierung in enger Abstimmung mit
den europäischen mit den
transatlantischen Partnern viel getan
und es war richtig jetzt auch
schrittweise vorzugehen und ich sage
hier auch es war richtig dass wir
versuchen jede diplomatische Möglichkeit
zu greifen die in den letzten Wochen da
war das war der richtige Weg kann man
diese russische Invasion noch stoppen
Melanie Ammann ist bei uns
Hauptstadtstudio des SPIEGEL geschätzte
Kollegin ist es möglich glauben Sie dass
es überhaupt noch gelingen wird und kam
die deutsche Regierung einfach mit allem
was sie jetzt tut zu spät
also es wäre denke ich nur möglich wenn
massive militärische Unterstützung von
außen für die Ukraine da käme denn da
stehen sicher wirklich ein David und ein
Goliath gegenüber nur dass der David
dieses Mal keine Schleuder hat also das
ist in dem Fall wirklich eine dermaßen
eine Übermacht von Russland dass die
Ukraine da völlig hilflos ist und sie
wird es zumindest was die
Bundesregierung angeht auch bleiben also
die solidaritätsadressen die kommen sind
zwar ernst gemeint sind scharf im Ton
sind klar aber da wird militärisch
nichts versprochen und da wird auch
nichts unternommen also die Solidarität
die nun gezeigt wird ist durch
Sanktionen ist eben durch ökonomischen
Druck durch den Versuch ökonomischer
abschreckungen aber wenn man ehrlich ist
mein Eindruck ist dass die
Bundesregierung das aufgegeben hat das
im Prinzip die die Ukraine jetzt dieser
Situation überlassen ist es gibt ja den
Satz von Olaf Scholz heute vom Tag wir
werden diesen Krieg gewinnen oder
andersrum putin wird diesen Krieg nicht
gewinnen was müsste passieren damit er
ihn gewinnt
ich denke putin wird diesen Krieg
gewinnen weil die russischen
Streitkräfte modern sind gut
ausgestattet sind weil sie eine
vielfache Überlegenheit auch haben weil
sie in der eine strategische
Ausgangsbasis haben gegen die man sich
einfach nicht verteidigen kann das ist
eine halbkreisförmigung der Ukraine die
ukrainischen Streitkräfte sind haben
veraltetes Gerät na ich sind in einer
wahnsinnig schlechten Position und trotz
Militärhilfe der Amerikaner und jetzt
auch neulich der Briten und Militärhilfe
jetzt noch zu leisten bringt nichts mehr
aktuell für den laufenden Konflikt das
alles reicht nicht also militärisch
gesehen ist die Sache gelaufen und meine
Bewertung ist dass es nur ein paar um
ein paar Tage gehen wird und und nicht
mehr es sei denn Putin macht den Schritt
in die Westukraine hier hat er mit
massiven Widerstand zu rechnen hier muss
er auch damit rechnen dass Teile der der
Streitkräfte weiter kämpfen Partisanen
grillakrieg abnutzungskrieg im Stile
Afghanistan aber das haben die Russen 8
Jahre auch erlebt wir als Euro starten
natürlich auch noch viel länger und er
wird das Vermeiden deswegen glaube ich
eben dass er nicht das gesamte Land
besetzen wird und den Westen der Ukraine
zum Beispiel nicht auf Dauer besetzen
wird er hat im Grunde schon 2008 ja
gesagt dass er Georgien und die Ukraine
nicht in der auf dem Weg der Freiheit
also in einen westlichen Bündnis dulden
wird warum ist man denn seitens der NATO
davon ausgegangen dass es bei der
Ukraine bei diesem Zuschauern bleiben
könnte also das ist ein gutes Stichwort
2008 war der NATO-Gipfel im Bukarest ich
kann mich sehr gut noch daran erinnern
ich war mit der Bundeskanzlerin damals
da und da war die gesamte NATO in der
Stimmung wir nehmen die Ukraine und
Georgien auf in das Bündnis es war sie
die gesagt hat nein das sollten wir
nicht machen das ist zu früh und zwar
damals nicht so sehr mit Blick auf
Russland sondern auf diese gespaltene
Situation auch innerhalb der Ukraine
damals war das nicht so klar und heute
haben ja welche russlandfreundlichen
Kräfte in der Ukraine darf man auch
nicht weg deklinieren unbedingt auch
noch da und zwar ziemlich massiv sie
haben vielleicht nicht mehr die Mehrheit
sie hat damals dafür gesorgt dass das
nicht passiert und das war auch ein
Weiser einer weise Entscheidung wir
haben damals sehr viel Kritik
eingefangen auch auf dem NATO-Gipfel
selber von anderen
NATO-Partnern aber es war richtig putin
war selber dabei wir hatten ja damals
noch diesen NATO Russland Rat aber für
mich war klar das war für ihn die rote
Linie wo er sich selbst gesagt hat hier
und nicht weiter und er hat ja dann auch
kurze Zeit später in dem Krieg mit
Georgien vollendete Tatsachen geschaffen
in nach einem ähnlichen Drehbuch über
uns wie wie jetzt in der Ukraine auch ja
transnistrieren
und auch hasien besetzt nicht die gesamt
das gesamte georgische Staatsgebiet
hatte damit ein Faustpfand geschaffen
dass eine NATO-Mitgliedschaft Georgiens
unmöglich macht und das ist jetzt bei
der Ukraine auch so wir werden auch aus
nato-sicht kein Land aufnehmen dass ein
in der staatlichen Konflikt hat mit
meinem Nachbarland und da sind wir
wieder bei dem Drehbuch die
US-amerikanischen Dienste sagen heute es
ist Teil 1 eines Drehbuches und es wird
den Russen gelingen die Ukraine zu
nehmen und dann ist nur die Frage für
den Westen wie lange kann man das Land
halten und verhindern dass Russland
genau dieses Gefühl hat oder das Putin
genau diese Sicherheit haben kann die
Ukraine im Grunde im Griff zu haben
denken sie dass die NATO mehr tun wird
als eben an den Grenzen nun hoch
bewaffnet zu stehen also sie kann im
Moment nicht mehr machen nicht das was
ihr macht ist halt die Abschreckung
hochfahren es ist kein Artikel 5 es ist
kein nato-vertragsgebiet das macht das
Ganze schwierig und wenn sich Putin auf
einen abnutzungskrieg einlassen würde
mit der Ukraine und die Ukraine weiter
um Waffen bittet dann gehen wir in schon
in eine Art Stellvertreterkrieg rein und
das muss man sich auch gut überlegen ob
man das tatsächlich will ob das die
richtige Strategie ist letztlich für den
Westen wie sehr Herr Klingbeil muss die
SPD grundsätzlich
studiere Verteidigungspolitik überlegen
Annegret Kramp-Karrenbauer ehemalige
Verteidigungsministerin sagt wir haben x
dieser Konflikte zugeschaut und haben
über etwas mehr Abschreckung
offensichtlich nie nachgedacht lassen
Sie mich noch einen Moment davor
ansetzen weil der fazi haben gerade
gesagt putin wird diesen Krieg gewinnen
und wahrscheinlich wird er diese
militärisch Auseinandersetzung gewinnen
aber ich glaube dass er auf lange Sicht
oder auf mittelfristige Sicht einen
großen Fehler gemacht hat mit dem
Einmarsch ins Ukraine die NATO noch mal
die vor anderthalb Jahren von macron als
Hirntod erklärt wurde ist so gestärkt
wie lange nicht mehr die
sicherheitspolitische Debatte und das
ist die Antwort auf die Frage die sie
gestellt haben wird sich fundamental
ändern in Deutschland ich glaube dass
wir das heißt wenn zwei Stunden entfernt
von Berlin jetzt militärisch
Auseinandersetzung stattfinden werden
wir ganz anders auf den Wert von
Sicherheit blicken wenn der festen
Überzeugung dass wir mehr Geld auch für
die Bundeswehr ausgeben müssen das ist
angelegt doch ein Koalitionsvertrag Olaf
Scholz hat das Finanzministerin schon
getan wir haben es ist interessant dass
Frau Kramp-Karrenbauer das sagt die auch
Verantwortung getragen hat in dem
Bereich 16 Jahre lang konservative an
der Spitze des Verteidigungsministeriums
aber es wird jetzt darum gehen die
Bundeswehr zu stärken die NATO zu
stärken die sicherheitspolitische
Debatte zu stärken und ich sage Ihnen es
kommt eine Diskussion nach oben drauf
wir haben über eine lange Zeit haben wir
das Konzept gehabt
Wandel durch Handel das heißt wir müssen
nur ökonomisch enge Beziehungen haben
mit autoritären Staaten und wir sehen
sowohl in der Frage China als auch in
der Frage Russland mit unterschiedlichen
Qualitäten aber bei beiden sehen wir es
dass dieses Konzept gescheitert ist und
wie ein anderen ein abschreckenderen
Umgang mit autoritären Staaten brauchen
und dass wir also nicht mehr darauf
hoffen können dass im Visa wie von China
und damit einem Staatskapitalismus und
im Visa wie von Putin man auf Handel und
Wandel setzen kann wir könnten jetzt
Herr klingen weil natürlich noch einen
draufsetzen ich muss Nord Streams 2
nicht nur in den Mund nehmen sondern
sagen diese Pipeline roch und sie roch
schon lange und sie ist auch weiter
gebaut worden von der Bundeskanzlerin
Agila Merkel ad jetzt erst hat sich die
SPD von ihr verabschiedet weil sie auch
zu spät gemerkt hat wie sehr dieses
Projekt schadet weil jetzt genau der
richtige Zeitpunkt war auch deutlich zu
machen dass jetzt der Stopp dazu gehört
also ich meine es gibt ja auch es gibt
ja auch Argumente für Nord Stream 2 aber
jetzt war der Zeitpunkt in dem es nicht
mehr vertretbar war dieses Projekt
weiter zu vertreten und weiter
voranzutreibende Zeitpunkt in der
Auseinandersetzung und das ist ja nicht
mal das ist ja keine Frage von SPD oder
sonst es gibt ja nur noch also auch die
Bundeskanzlerin hat das Projekt nicht
gestoppt und die war ja und auch lang im
Amt aber noch mal jetzt war der richtige
Zeitpunkt auch als Signal als wichtiges
Signal an die russische Seite ihr habt
hier eine Grenze überschritten und
deswegen würden trotzdem zwei gestoppt
noch mal eine Frage dazu es ist ja lange
von Olaf Scholz nach einer von einer
privatwirtschaftlichen Initiative
gesprochen worden und anderes mehr auch
angeht auch die Ministerpräsidentin von
Schleswig-Holstein hat sich entsprechend
geäußert haben wir den richtigen
Zeitpunkt verpasst also wir haben
mehrere Zeitpunkte verpasst wenn es
heißt das jetzt der richtige Zeitpunkt
war wenn Sie das sagen dann würde ich
sagen es war der die aller aller
geschätzte Möglichkeit ist noch
gesichtswaren kann man es eigentlich
nicht mehr sagen aber es war wirklich
die letzte Möglichkeit dieses Projekt
noch zu stoppen ohne sich völlig
unmöglich zu machen und ich erinnere
mich noch als sie haben jetzt gesagt
dass es so viele Konservative
Verteidigungsminister gegeben hätte es
gab ja auch zum Beispiel eine
sozialdemokratischen Außenminister
mehrere und ich weiß noch wie Heiko Maas
zu Beginn seiner Amtszeit versucht hat
eine schärfere in russland-politik zu
bewirken er hat 2018 gesagt wir müssen
uns darauf einstellen Russland ist
agiert zunehmend feindselig uns
gegenüber das war nach der
krim-geschichte das war nach dem
ukrainekrieg das war nach vielen Toten
und da wie wurde er da von der
SPD-Spitze sie waren damals
Generalsekretär wie wurde er da
zurückgepfiffen wie wurde er da
zusammengefaltet für diese völlig
unverständliche Position und wie kann
man nur und das räumt doch das
Prinzipien unserer Ostpolitik ab und so
also da hat da hat die SPD schon ein
gewisses russland-problem seit Jahren
gab dass ich eben durch diese Pipeline
manifestierte wenn man so will und wenn
man sieht die ihre Kollegin Manuela
Schwesig dieses Projekt ja auch noch in
allen Kräften irgendwie juristisch
abgesichert hat mit dieser Stiftung in
Mecklenburg-Vorpommern und wieder immer
wieder auch der Kontakt und der Rat von
Herrn Schröder gesucht wurde unserem
Altkanzler also ich finde das sieht da
sieht die SPD jetzt nicht sehr gut aus
in diesem ganzen Thema
dazu noch einen Satz ich habe ja gerade
als Vorsitzender der SPD gesprochen so
und ich meine wir sind an einem Tag wo
mitten in Europa ein Krieg ausbricht und
wenn sie so manche Debatte manche
Debatte was vor ein paar Jahren mal war
die kann man jetzt gerne führen aber die
Frage auch die Partner in Europa
unterstellen natürlich der
sozialdemokratischen Regierung ich
erlebe in den letzten Tagen und ich war
selbst viel unterwegs ich habe mit
vielen auch befreundeten Vorsitzenden
von von Schwesterparteien in Europa auch
zum Beispiel ein Großbritannien jetzt
Kontakt gehabt und Olaf Scholz ist
gerade eine der zentralen wenn ich sogar
die zentrale Person neben macron in
Europa die gerade es schafft die
Verbündeten zu sammeln den Weg
vorzugeben den Weg zu ein und den Weg
auch vorzutragen und insofern hat die
SPD an dieser Stelle 0
Glaubwürdigkeitsproblem sondern sorgt
gerade dafür dass Deutschland außen
sicherheitspolitische vernünftig
Auftritt Marina weißband in Münster sie
sind grünen Politikerin Robert Habeck
hat im Sommer des letzten Jahres gesagt
dieses Land die Ukraine braucht
wenigstens defensivwaffen ich
verteidigen zu können haben die Grünen
die rot regierte sie sozialdemokratisch
regierte ampelregierung da zum Jagen
getragen
ich würde mich ungern jetzt in die
Niederungen von Parteipolitik vertiefen
an diesem Tag ich glaube insgesamt hat
Deutschland viel zu spät gehandelt in
Sachen defensiv Waffen die 5000 Helme
waren ein schlechter Witz sie wurden von
der Ukraine auch als Beleidigung
empfunden und ja man hätte früher
handeln müssen aber es gibt an diesem
Konflikt genug Leute die Dinge verpasst
haben seit acht Jahren seit acht Jahren
verpassen wir die Propaganda mit der
Putin sein eigenes Volk vorbereitet hat
in der erzählt hat dass in der Ukraine
nur Nazis sein und russischsprachige
unterdrückt würden was bei einem
russischsprachigen Juden als Präsidenten
sehr sehr lächerlich ist aber
Schuld an diesem Konflikt ist nur eine
und das ist Putin deswegen würde ich
mich jetzt ungern ergehen in einer
Analyse dessen wer hat wann welchen
Fehler gemacht sondern ich finde es
jetzt viel wichtiger uns darauf zu
konzentrieren wo können wir von heute an
hingehen und vielleicht ein neues
Verständnis im Westen zu schaffen dafür
wie radikal die russische Politik agiert
und bereit ist zu agieren und dass sie
nicht an den ukrainischen Grenzen stehen
bleiben wird und das ist dann die
logische nächste Frage Marina weißband
glauben Sie denn tatsächlich dass es
gelingen wird dass es dem Westen
gelingen wird dass es dem ukrainischen
Volk gelingen wird
diesem Goliath nicht nur
entgegenzutreten sondern ihn aufzuhalten
ich sehe keine militärische Einmischung
des Westens so lange der Konflikt in der
Ukraine ist was die Ukraine selbst
betrifft werden sie nicht aufgeben das
kann in einer sehr sehr schmutzige Lage
führen was tatsächlich Afghanistan nicht
unähnlich wäre und beiden hat schon
Präsident beiden hat schon vor Wochen
solche Andeutungen gemacht dass man aus
der Ukraine im Zweifel ein zweites
Afghanistan macht und ich denke für ihn
ist es auch nicht unwillkommen wenn
Putin jetzt diesen Fehler gemacht hat
einzumarschieren das schneidet Russland
von der internationalen Gemeinschaft ab
und das kann für die Ukraine eine sehr
lange und sehr blutige Zeit werden ich
denke wenn wir diesen Konflikt gewinnen
wollen und mit wir meine ich die
gesamtschaft demokratischer Staaten dann
geht das nicht ohne die Hilfe einer
Partei nämlich der russischen
Bevölkerung wir sehen heute
Demonstrationen in Moskau und in St
Petersburg und ja die sind nicht
gewaltig aber dafür dass jeder verhaftet
wird der mit einem auf die Straße geht
sind sie schon groß wenn wir es schaffen
zu der russischen Bevölkerung zu
kommunizieren durch die Maßnahmen die
wir geben durch aber auch soziale Medien
durch die Kommunikation die uns möglich
ist glaube ich können wir Putin stürzen
und ich glaube das wäre die einzige
Sicherheitsgarantie für Europa das wäre
ein demokratisches Russland wie sehr
waren sie überrascht von dem was heute
Nacht geschehen ist
ich war überrascht von der Heftigkeit
und von der Geschwindigkeit ich dachte
dass es länger brauchen würde bis er in
Kiew ist aber ich habe schon seit Tagen
eigentlich nächtlich damit gerechnet
dass es irgendwann passiert in den
frühen Morgenstunden und ich bin
regelmäßig um vier aufgestanden um zu
gucken ob es passiert insofern man hat
es schon kommen sehen aber ich glaube
von der Heftigkeit sind auch die meisten
Ukraine überrascht wie ist Deutschland
vorbereitet wenn und auch darin kann ein
Teil der Hilfe bestehen das klingt bei
wenn viele Flüchtlinge kommen
Nancy fazer hat als
bundesinnenministerin ja deutlich
gemacht dass wir darauf vorbereitet sind
sowohl in der Abstimmung mit den
Bundesländern aber auch in der
Abstimmung mit den europäischen Partnern
haben wir dann eine humanitäre
Verpflichtung für Menschen die jetzt
vertrieben werden in Ukraine auch ja
einzustehen und sie aufzunehmen
Melanie Ammann das ist nicht eine der
nächsten logischen Aufgaben auch für
diese Regierung und für diesen Staat was
glauben sie können wir darüber hinaus in
Bezug auf eben eine neue Russland und
Verteidigungspolitik tun was denken sie
wie wird das Aussehen und wie schnell
ist es zu verändern
ich habe heute Frau Lambrecht gehört die
gesagt hat sie sei sozusagen was auch
immer jetzt die NATO in der nächsten
Zeit von uns verlangt wir werden es
liefern und wir können es liefern Herr
Ford kann besser beurteilen ob wir dazu
wirklich in der Lage sind ich habe ein
bisschen Zweifel ob das ein Versprechen
war das vielleicht ein bisschen zu
schnell kann man wir haben schon tausend
Soldaten ungefähr Soldatinnen und
Soldaten in Litauen und wir haben
Aufklärungsflüge
aber wir haben was ob wir da wirklich
jetzt alles liefern können was die NATO
von uns verlangt ich glaube da kommen
noch unangenehme Debatten auf
Deutschland zu wir sind genau bei der
Frage hat was die Bundeswehr zusätzlich
bräuchte das haben wir alle auch schon
lange genug angemahnt und diskutiert
auch in diesen Sendungen diskutiert die
einen sagen wir haben Putin zu wenig
abgeschreckt die anderen sagen wir haben
an den falschen Stellen zu wenig mit ihm
geredet darf ich sie nach dieser
politischen Einschätzung fragen was
denken Sie wie lange wird es in Europa
nun einen Krieg geben also ich glaube
einfach dass der Konflikt auch zeigt
dass wenn man keine Militär hat man
keine schlagkräftigen Streitkräfte hat
auch in den internationalen Beziehungen
in der Außenpolitik schnell angrenzen
stößt ich meine wer sind die
Krisenmanager die Sitze in Washington in
Moskau und im Peking und wo ist da
Europa wo ist dieser viel
Geschworene europäische
sicherheitspolitische Akteur ich sehe
ihn nicht kann nämlich erkennen na ich
und haben die überhaupt Einfluss auf den
Gang der Dinge nein wir haben es nicht
und wir werden letztlich auch von Putin
nicht ernst genommen weil wir diese
militärische Schlagkraft als Europäer
jedenfalls nicht haben sondern nur im
Rahmen der NATO die Amerikaner nimmt der
Ernst und damit auch die NATO weil die
Amerikaner in der NATO sind das ist der
Punkt dabei und der Zustand der
Bundeswehr klingen weil sie haben sie
angesprochen der ist so schlecht ich
meine ein Grund warum man keine Waffen
geliefert haben an die Ukraine war ganz
banal weil unsere Depots leer sind weil
die Bundeswehr selber nicht genug
Ausrüstung hat für die laufenden
Einsätze Schutzwesten zum Beispiel und
die Helme waren übrig und das wurde dann
zu einem naja zu einer Nummer so wie wie
man sie also auch gerne sieht weil ich
das muss man eben sehen und die
schlussfolgung ist daraus tatsächlich
wir müssen als Europäer darüber
nachdenken wie wir uns
verteidigungspolitisch auch
sicherheitspolitisch aufstellen und zwar
ohne diese ständigen Visionen von
europäischer Armee strategische
Autonomie die so und so so weit weg von
der Realität sind nicht also es geht
eigentlich nur um eine starkes Europa
innerhalb des transatlantischen
Bündnisses das ist im Moment mit den USA
auch zugegebenermaßen schwer und es kann
auch sein in drei Jahren das ist dann
noch schwerer wird aber umso wichtiger
ist das Europa da auch handlungsfähig
wird und das sieht man hier sehr sehr
deutlich da ist gar nichts das ist sehr
schreckend winzigen Hoffnungsschimmer in
dieser Katastrophe gibt es ist ja
vielleicht tatsächlich auch Polen jetzt
anders entwickeln könnte also mein Polen
als NATO-Mitglied wird in einer völlig
anderen Situation sein wenn wirklich die
Ukraine unter de facto russische
Kontrolle gerät als Grenzland von
Belarus ist man da ohnehin schon Kummer
gewöhnt aber das jetzt sozusagen diese
völlige fahrlagens entlang ganz eigenen
Grenzen dann von russischer Dominanz das
wird glaube ich die Debatte dort im Land
und auf europäischer Ebene das kann man
mit Sicherheit sagen das hat Putin
geschafft er hat die Europäer wieder
enger zueinander geführt und auch die
NATO-Staaten wieder enger zueinander
geführt ganz herzliches Dankeschön nach
Münster zu Marina weißband für alles was
sie uns gesagt haben heute und alles
Gute für ihre Freunde ihre Familie und
für die Menschen natürlich in der
Ukraine und Ihnen hier im Studio ganz
herzlichen Dank ich gebe sofort zu
Matthias Fornoff in Mainz danke Maybrit
Illner nach Berlin später gibt es ja
noch eine zweite Gesprächsrunde mit
Maybrit Illner
in der Zwischenzeit ist der russische
Beschuss von militärischen Einrichtungen
aber auch Städten in der Ukraine
ungebremst weitergegangen wir bringen
Sie jetzt noch mal auf den aktuellsten
Stand der Lage
bringen ich habe die Entscheidung für
eine Militäroperation getroffen um
Menschen zu schützen die seit acht
Jahren einem Völkermord durch das Regime
in Kiew ausgesetzt waren
Vladimir Putin überfällt die Ukraine in
den frühen Morgenstunden mehrere Städte
werden angegriffen aus der Luft vom
Boden und vom Wasser aus der ukrainische
Präsident selenski fängt das Kriegsrecht
und ruft in einer Videobotschaft gegen
5:30 Uhr dazu auf nicht in Panik zu
verfallen man sei auf alles vorbereitet
und werde siegen in der Hauptstadt Kiew
heulen die Sirenen Bombenalarm Trümmer
liegen in einer Geschäftsstraße herum
die Menschen realisieren es ist Krieg
[Musik]
zuerst hörte ich eine furchtbare
Explosion mit Unglaub Gewalt ich sprang
auf und ich wusste nicht wohin ich gehen
sollte ich bekam Panik
9 Uhr
bundesaußenministerin baerbock tritt vor
die Presse verurteilt mit scharfen
Worten den russischen Einmarsch mit dem
militärischen Angriff auf die Ukraine
bricht die russische Regierung vor den
Augen der Welt mit den elementarsten
Regeln der internationalen Ordnung
unterdessen bilden sich an Kiews
Tankstellen und Banken lange Schlangen
die Straßen der Hauptstadt verstopft die
Menschen wollen nur noch weg etliche
folgen dem Aufruf des Gesundheitsamtes
freiwillig Blut zu spenden
MitbürgerInnen um 18 Uhr wendet sich
Bundeskanzler Scholz direkt an die
Fernsehzuschauer gerade erleben wir den
Beginn eines Krieges wie wir in Europa
so seit mehr als 75 Jahren nicht erlebt
haben
russlands Präsident Putin hat die
Entscheidung getroffen die Ukraine
militärisch anzugreifen das ist ein
Überfall auf ein unabhängiges souveränes
Land
es durch nichts und durch niemanden
zurechtfertigen
seit dem frühen Abend demonstrieren
Menschen auf der ganzen Welt wie hier in
Berlin gegen den russischen Angriff auf
die Ukraine und für Frieden auch in
Novosibirsk gehen die Menschen auf die
Straßen
US-Präsident beiden spricht um 19 Uhr 45
seine Botschaft und missverständlich
[Musik]
ist der Adresse Putin hat sich diesen
Krieg gewählt und jetzt werden er und
sein Land die Konsequenzen tragen ich
autorisiere heute zusätzliche starke
Sanktionen und neue Einschränkungen auf
das was im exportiert werden kann nach
Russland dass wir Tor Kosten für die
russische Wirtschaft bedeuten sofort und
langfristig und auch beim
EU-Sondergipfel der Regierungschefs geht
es zur Stunde in Brüssel um weitere
Sanktionen gegen Russland
und in Berlin begrüße ich jetzt Marina
Henke Professorin an der hertis cool und
Expertin für Sicherheitspolitik guten
Abend hallo guten Abend
Krieg in Europa im 21 Jahrhundert über
Feld Russland die Ukraine hätten sie das
so für Möglichkeiten
wir Spezialisten haben damit leider
schon lange spekuliert ja es ist eine
absolute Tragik und ich wünschte es wäre
nicht passiert aber für uns war es nicht
etwas dass völlig vom Himmel kam
was will Putin das fragt sich die Welt
jetzt schon seit Wochen und Monaten was
ist sein Ziel in der Ukraine Vormarsch
auf Kiew Angriff von drei Seiten bringt
Russland die Ukraine vollständig
vollständig unter seine Kontrolle
er sagt er möchte und das sind seine
Worte nicht meine Worte die Ukraine D
natifizieren und den militarisieren aber
wenn Sie mich fragen hat es vor allem
innenpolitische Gründe Putin fühlt sich
eigentlich in politisch schwach er hat
eine Opposition die immer stärker und
stärker wird und um die Repressionen
gegen diese Opposition zu rechtfertigen
brauche einen Feind und er hat sich NATO
er hat sich die USA hat sich den Westen
als den Feind ausgesucht und so wird ja
auch diese Kampagne in der Ukraine
gerade
porträtiert als eine
verteidigungskampagne gegen den Westen
gegen nahto gegen die Vereinten Nationen
ja mit der deutschen Wiedervereinigung
und dem Zerfall der Sowjetunion war die
Hoffnung auf einen dauerhaften Frieden
in Europa verbunden wie groß ist die
Gefahr dass ich in Europa jetzt wieder
zwei militärische Blöcke feindlich
gegenüberstehen Kalter Krieg 2.0
auf eine gewisse Weise leider ja
NATO wird jetzt diese
Wirtschaftssanktionen natürlich
implementieren weil auf der
militärischen Seite geht es jetzt vor
allem darum die NATO-Staaten zu
beschützen und im Großen und Ganzen
werden wir jetzt auf jeden Fall zwei
wirtschaftsblöcke sehen Russland wird
sich mehr und mehr China zuwenden auch
um natürlich die Güter und die
Dienstleistungen die es jetzt nicht mehr
über die westlichen Staaten beziehen
kann über China Beziehung zu können und
so wird ja wieder ein eiserner Vorhang
fallen ja vielen Dank auch für diesen
Blick nach vorn Frau Professor Henke in
Berlin vielen Dank
an der polnischen ukrainischen Grenze
kamen den ganzen Tag über die ersten
Flüchtlinge aus der Ukraine an in
chemisch 80 Kilometer westlich von
Lemberg begrüße ich jetzt unsere
Korrespondentin Natalie Steger
natalievers haben Sie heute den Tag über
gesehen und erlebt wie ist diese
Situation an der Grenze zur Ukraine
jetzt
also ganz aktuell hier am Bahnhof vom
chemische kommen immer noch Menschen an
mit den Zug aktuell ist ein Zug aus Kiew
angekommen die ganze Nacht über soll das
gehen es sind hunderte hier angekommen
sagen uns die Behörden und man will den
Menschen helfen hier ist zum Beispiel
eingerichtet worden ein Infopunkt da
wird den Menschen gesagt wie sie
weiterkommen können wohin sie gehen
können man bietet Transportmöglichkeiten
an es werden unheimlich viele Fragen
gestellt auch uns hat man gefragt zum
Beispiel wie es Warschau wie weit ist
Berlin und eine traurige Geschichte es
sind viele hier eine Frau hat gesagt ich
will jetzt weiter nach Deutschland sie
hat ein kleines Kind auf dem Arm gehabt
in Deutschland habe ich Verwandtschaft
aber mein Mann ist in der Ukraine
geblieben und muss das Land verteidigen
ja und den ganzen Tag über sie haben es
gesagt sind Menschen hier angekommen
viele zu Fuß nur mit dem was sie mit
transportieren können und natürlich mit
sehr vielen sorgen nicht nur wie es
Ihnen geht wie es mit ihnen weitergeht
sondern vor allem was mit ihrem Land
passiert ob und sind sie zurück können
wie es den Angehörigen geht die nicht
rausgekommen sind also das sind viele
Menschen voller Sorge da haben wir viel
Tränen und viel Unglück gesehen die
Polen nicht nur hier sondern auch an der
Grenze Privatleute helfen Busfahrer sind
gekommen um beim Transport zu helfen
private Leute mit dem PKW und haben
gesagt steigt ein wir fahren euch wohin
also die Hilfswelle ist recht groß so
haben wir das erlebt und eine
interessante Sache von Polen nach
Ukraine in die andere Richtung haben wir
gehört es gibt immer wieder Ukrainer die
in Polen leben und arbeiten und die
jetzt tatsächlich zurück wollen und
sagen wir müssen kämpfen
vielen Dank Nathalie Steger für diese
Eindrücke
und in Düsseldorf begrüße ich den
außenpolitischen Sprecher der
cdu/csu-bundestagsfraktion guten Abend
Herr hart guten Abend wie steht die
größte Oppositionspartei zu dem
russischen Überfall auf die Ukraine
wir sind erschüttert von den Bildern die
wir erreichen aus der Ukraine wir haben
das natürlich als schlimmstes
Möglichstes Szenario durchaus auch im
Geiste durchgespielt aber wenn es jetzt
passiert ist es noch mal erschütternder
und ich habe es noch vor wenigen Monaten
für völlig ausgeschlossen haben dass Sie
ein solches Szenario mitten in Europa
möglich ist und wir verurteilen das auf
schärfste und wir sagen aber auch jetzt
ist nicht die Zeit in der die Opposition
rumäkeln muss an dem ein oder anderen
Wimpernschlag den die Regierung hier und
dort tut sondern hier geht es darum dass
wir die Politik der Bundesregierung
unterstützen dass wir ihr Erfolg
wünschen in unser aller Interesse und
dass wir uns konstruktiv zu dieser
besonderen Herausforderung für
Deutschland stellen die ehemalige
Verteidigungsministerin
Kramp-Karrenbauer hat heute getwittert
ich zitiere wir haben die Lehre von
Schmidt und Kohl vergessen das
Verhandlungen Vorrang haben man aber
militärisch so stark sein muss dass
nicht verhandeln für die andere Seite
keine Option ist zit am Ende haben wir
uns über Jahrzehnte zu sicher gefühlt
und zu wenig getan das ist natürlich
einerseits richtig was Annegret
Kramp-Karrenbauer gesagt hat es ist
allerdings auch in der Ukraine eine
besondere Situation wir haben ja stets
betont dass wir uns nicht an einer
militärischen Verteidigung der Ukraine
beteiligen wollen wir wollen nicht mit
deutschen Soldaten gegen russische
Soldaten auf ukrainischem Bode wurden in
den Krieg ziehen darüber kann man
diskutieren ich halte das nach wie vor
für die richtige Haltung und damit war
im Grunde die Option unsererseits den
konfliktmilitärisch zu lösen vom Tisch
und das hat dem skrupellosen Putin
natürlich die Sache durchaus erleichtert
ich glaube wir müssen darüber nachdenken
wie wir zukünftig und zwar halten
gegenüber Staaten die zwar nicht zur
NATO gehören die aber zu unserem
westlichen wertebündnis gehören und die
unsere Solidarität erwarten können
zumindest was die militärische
Ausrüstung und Ausbildung dieser Länder
angeht können sie glaube ich zukünftig
mehr auf uns setzen als das im Fall der
Ukraine leider gewesen ist die Ukraine
zu entwaffnen die Regierung zu stürzen
das scheinen die Ziele Putins zu sein
ist das überhaupt noch zu verhindern
ich hoffe dass es einen Weg gibt es zu
verhindern ich glaube auch dass die
ukrainischen Streitkräfte auch
entschlossen sind und auch fähig sind
bestimmte Dinge zu tun die putinen auch
weh tun ich glaube am Ende des Tages
wird Putin auf mittlere und längere
Sicht feststellen dass es ungeheuer
schwer ist ein Land wie die Ukraine das
wirklich auch unter diesem russischen
Druck in den letzten Jahren ja immer
mehr sich desto westlichen Werten
Demokratie und Freiheit bekannt hat
dieses Land unter Kontrolle zu halten
und ich kann mir gut vorstellen dass
schon in wenigen Monaten man im Gremmel
Putin fragt was hast du dir eigentlich
gedacht bei diesem Experiment es kostet
ein Haufen Geld es kostet unsere
Reputation des ruiniert unsere
Wirtschaft und es bringt nichts für die
Entwicklung Russlands das ist ja das
Drama wir könnten ja Russland könnte
sich ja wirtschaftlich und
gesellschaftlich in einer
ausgezeichneten Art und Weise entwickeln
als Partner Europas als großer
Gaslieferant als Partner Wissenschaft
und Kultur in gemeinsamen großen
Projekten wie etwa dem Klimaschutz
darauf verzichtet Putin weil er Angst
hat dass die Werte und die Vorstellungen
Westeuropas nämlich zum Beispiel
unabhängige Gerichte Freiheit der
Meinung dass die eines Tages auch in
Moskau Fuß fassen denn das wäre das Ende
seiner Herrschaft und deswegen tut er
das Krieg gegen die Freiheit hat das
Friedrich Merz genannt vielen Dank für
das Gespräch nach Düsseldorf auf
Wiedersehen
viele haben alles getan um zu verhindern
was heute morgen dann doch begonnen hat
es war geradezu ein Feuerwerk der
Diplomatie es hat Putin nicht vom
Kriegspfad abbringen können wir schauen
uns noch mal die Versuche und das
letztendliche Scheitern der letzten Tage
an
Freuden Feuerwerk im Donbass vor drei
Tagen pro russische Separatisten feiern
Wladimir Putin in der Ferne jenseits der
ukrainischen Grenzen hat der russische
Präsident einen weitreichenden
Entschluss getroffen
[Musik]
übrigens ich halte es für notwendig eine
längst ausgereifte Entscheidung zu
treffen die unverzügliche Anerkennung
der Unabhängigkeit und Souveränität der
Volksrepublik Don jetzt und der
Volksrepublik luhansk zwei russische
Milizenführer und Putin ordnen die
Ukraine neu diese Tinte zerstört de
facto die Souveränität eines
europäischen Staates und Putin sieht
sich damit im Recht
die Ukraine hat gar keine
eigenstaatliche Tradition sondern hat
immer nur andere kopiert
und die Bedürfnisse einer macht Elite
befriedigt über die Köpfe des Volkes
hinweg
Putin befiehlt die Entsendung von
Truppen in die Ostukraine er nennt es
eine Friedensmission aber das kauft ihm
spätestens jetzt niemand mehr ab
Deutschland appelliert wir fordern
Russland auf die Entscheidung rückgängig
zu machen und den Weg wieder
freizumachen zu diplomatischen und
politischen Konfliktlösung im Sinne der
Minsker Vereinbarung zurückzukehren die
Europäische Union protestiert
diese Entscheidung Truppen in die
Ostukraine zu entsenden können wir nicht
akzeptieren Russland missachtet die
territoriale Integrität und Souveränität
der Ukraine
Russland achtet seine internationalen
Verpflichtungen nicht und missachtet
Kernprinzipien des Völkerrechts
die EU bringt ein Sanktionspaket auf den
Weg Deutschland liegt Nord Stream 2 auf
Eis und neben Finanzsanktionen gegen
Moskau kündigt US-Präsident beiden auch
die Bewegung von Soldaten an
unsere baltischen Partner zu stärken
verlegen wir weitere US-Truppen die
schon in Europa sind nach Estland
Lettland und Litauen lassen Sie mich das
klarstellen von unserer Seite aus sind
das rein Defensive Schritte
alle Bemühungen bis heute ändern für die
Ukraine nichts ein russischer
Angriffskrieg hat begonnen den Putin in
der Nacht anordnet und eine
schutzmission nennt allerdings nur für
die ihm treu ergebenen Separatisten und
ihre Anhänger
ich habe beschlossen eine spezielle
Militäroperation durchzuführen ihr Ziel
ist der Schutz von Menschen die acht
Jahre lang leiden mussten unter
Missbrauch und Völkermord durch das
Regime in Kiews
und so neblig verschleiernt diese Worte
sind andere sind erschreckend klar
wer auch immer versucht uns zu stoppen
und unser Land und seine Leute bedroht
sollte wissen
russlandsreaktion wird sofort erfolgen
und zu Konsequenzen für sie führen wie
Sie sie noch nie in ihrer Geschichte
erlebt haben
Russland führt jetzt Krieg in der
Ukraine und dass dieser Krieg nicht auf
das Gebiet der Ukraine begrenzt bleibt
die Angst ist größer denn je
und ich begrüße jetzt Marcel rötig den
Leiter der Friedrich-Ebert-Stiftung in
der Ukraine sie haben Kiew auf
Empfehlung des Auswärtigen Amtes
verlassen wir erreichen Sie jetzt in der
Stadt jasch in Rumänien natürlich sind
aber ihre Gedanken jetzt auch bei Ihren
örtlichen Mitarbeitern in der Ukraine
was hören sie denn da wie ist die
Situation heute Abend
wir stehen tatsächlich im sehr guten
Austausch trotz der Tatsache dass der
Internetverbindung dann doch manchmal
zum Erliegen kommen es sieht jetzt so
aus dass meine Kolleginnen und Kollegen
diese Nacht in Kellern verbringen werden
teilweise ohne Licht oder auf
gefährlichen Straßen auf eine
beschwerlichen Weg nach Westen um das
den Zuschauerinnen und Zuschauern mal
klar zu machen was hier passiert wir
haben eine Kollegin die ist schwanger
wird in den nächsten Tagen ein Kind zur
Welt bringen wir haben eine andere
Kollegin die mit einem ganz kleinen Kind
gerade auf dem Weg in den Westen ist und
wir haben Ehemänner die gestern und
heute ihre Familien verlassen haben die
Waffe genommen haben und in diesen
Stunden Kiew verteidigen in den letzten
Tagen hat der ukrainische Präsident
selenski ja eher versucht zu beruhigen
heute hat er gesagt er meldet sich aus
einem Land von dem er nicht wisse wie
lange ist das noch gibt und als
Präsident der nicht weiß wie lange er
selbst noch am Leben sein wird welches
Schicksal droht der Ukraine
ich fürchte was wir erleben ist eine Art
blitzkekszenario gemünzt auf das 21
jahrhunderts haben Sie sicherlich damit
zu rechnen dass wir in den frühen
Morgenstunden eine Luft landau-operation
in Kiel erleben werden das
die Regierung gestürzt wird ein
Marionettenregime eingesetzt wird was
dann nach Moskau aus frei für tanzt also
natürlich die Krim und den Donbass
weggibt den NATO-Beitritt verwirft die
militarisiert aber das schlimmste auch
dass wir möglicherweise das Ende der
ukrainischen Demokratie erleben das Ende
der Demokratie in der Ukraine wie wir
sie auch mit unserer Hilfe aufgebaut
haben in den letzten Jahren schon jetzt
versuchen ja viele das Land unter
Beschuss zu verlassen wir haben die
Bilder eben gesehen wie schätzen Sie das
ein wer kann flieht
für viele scheint es zu spät zu sein das
muss man auch sagen heute morgen
diejenigen die sich frühzeitig auf den
Weg gemacht haben in den frühen
Morgenstunden sind jetzt so langsam
Richtung leviv unterwegs haben auch
unterwegs Beschuss gesehen oder Kämpfe
gesehen wir haben diejenigen die erst im
Nachmittag sich losgemacht haben die
noch nicht mal den Kiel bei Oblast
verlassen konnten weil die Staus einfach
so massiv sind
dass es kaum möglich ist voranzukommen
wir müssen mit einer enormen
Flüchtlingswelle rechnen in den nächsten
Tagen und Wochen wir haben damit unsere
Erfahrung in Deutschland Polen und die
osteuropäischen Staaten werden diese
Erfahrung jetzt machen aber das was da
jetzt auf uns zukommt wird noch ja wird
noch sehr gravierend sein und wird uns
für immer in Erinnerung bleiben sie und
ihre Leute erleben da auffüllende und
gefährliche Tage ich wünsche Ihnen dafür
alles Gute bleiben Sie gesund und danke
für das Geschenk
und wir geben noch mal ab nach Berlin in
den ZDF zollernhof wo Maybrit Illner
eine weitere Gesprächsrunde versammelt
hat maybrit vielen Dank Matthias ja als
er vorschlug der Ukraine defensivwaffen
zu liefern war die Empörung groß Robert
Habeck der Vizekanzler ist gleich
zugeschaltet es gibt Krieg in der
Ukraine die Welt reagiert mit
solidaritätsadressen was kann sie sonst
noch tun das will ich Ihnen Fragen und
meine Gäste es sind immer noch aus der
spiegelchefredakteur-redaktion Melanie
Ammann bei uns und auch Erich Fahrt
gerade general ade lange Berater der
Bundeskanzlerin Angela Merkel ade Robert
Habeck einen guten Abend zu ihnen wir
haben auch in der Sendung vorhin den
Botschafter der Ukraine Melnik gehört
der sich darüber beklagte dass die
Deutschen zu spät und zu zaghaft die
Sanktionen ausgerufen haben ihre
Reaktion darauf
guten Abend der kein guter Abend ist
Sanktionen waren dazu da den Krieg zu
verhindern das muss man einräumen das
hat nicht geklappt es war ein
dropotenzial das Putin nicht hat
abschrecken lassen ob das jemals möglich
gewesen wäre ist eine Frage die ich
heute abend er verneinen würde wenn man
jetzt die Schriften von Putin aus dem
Sommer liest wenn man sich anschaut mit
welcher Kaltblütigkeit dieser Krieg
vorbereitet wurde muss man einräumen das
wahrscheinlich kein drop-potenzial stark
genug gewesen wäre Putin abzuschrecken
deswegen
verstehe ich den Schmerz den Zorn die
Enttäuschung auch das Gefühl alleine
gelassen zu sein der Ukrainer und des
Botschafters und wahrscheinlich von
allen Menschen vollumfänglich so würde
ich auch reden und ich glaube so muss
man auch reden und da ist auch viel
Wahres dran
denn so richtig können wir der Ukraine
nicht helfen und wir helfen ihr auch
nicht aber die Sanktion früher zu
verengen hätte kein Unterschied gemacht
wir haben Olaf Scholz den Bundeskanzler
heute gehört mit dem Satz putin wird
diesen Krieg nicht gewinnen
was würde sie den Vizekanzler dieses
Landes Habeck da so sicher machen und
was macht Olaf Scholz so sicher
autokarten und Diktaturen Leben in Angst
und halten ihre Bevölkerung in Angst und
werden deswegen auf Dauer immer die
schwächeren sein am Ende werden die
Menschen immer mit ihrer Hoffnung mit
ihrem Mut mit dem Streben nach Freiheit
über die Diktaturen siegen
das Tragische ist dass dieses am Ende
manchmal ein bisschen länger dauert aber
in dem Sinne wird Putin als Verlierer
aus diesem Krieg herausgehen weil er
keine Freunde mehr haben wird jedenfalls
nicht in der freien Welt rational ist
dieser Krieg nicht zu erklären er ist
es ist eine Idiotie wenn ich das so
sagen darf weil jetzt der Westen sich
von Putin von Russland vom Putin
Russland als Handelspartner als
Geschäftspartner komplett abkehren wird
denn mit Kriegstreibern kann man ja
keine Geschäfte machen und das sieht
jetzt jeder
kurzfristig so sieht es ja aus ist ja
militärisch natürlich in der Vorhand
wir haben gerade Lars Klingbeil bei uns
in der Sendung gehabt auch Ihnen
natürlich danach befragt wie konzise und
klar und eindeutig die Haltung der SPD
in diesem Fall sein konnte und war auch
an Sie die Frage habe ich wie sehr haben
sie viel früher Reaktionen der deutschen
Regierung und des deutschen
Bundeskanzlers gewünscht
ich denke über den Winter über den
Dezember übergab es noch viel Hoffnung
und auch viel Versuche mit intakten
Beziehung zu Russland das Fenster die
Tür zu Diplomatie offen zu halten und
das ist ja allerern wert also wir können
ja nicht akzeptieren dass Krieg als
Mittel der Politik wieder normal wird es
gibt einen strategischen Fehler
wahrscheinlich gibt es mehrere aber
einer ist klar zu sehen den Deutschland
gemacht hat das ist sich
energiepolitisch abhängig zu machen von
einem Despoten und einem Diktator und
einem Kriegstreiber wie man jetzt sieht
und hätten wir energiepolitisch mehr
Freiheit mehr Freiraum wären wir nicht
so abhängig von russischem Gas von
russischer Kohle wäre Nord Stream 2 nie
geplant und nie genehmigt und nicht
gebaut worden
dann hätten wir souveräne agieren können
wir sind bei Gerhard Schröder wir sind
bei der Frage Angela Merkel
Bundeskanzlerin hat Nord Stream ja auch
mitgebaut wir sind bei der Frage wie
sehr diese Pipeline tatsächlich schon
roch und übelroch und nur die
Sozialdemokratie hat das zum Schluss
nicht mitbekommen
es gibt viele Menschen in der SPD die
diese Pipeline bewusst gewollt gefördert
und vielleicht auch von ihr profitiert
haben aber auch die ganze große
Koalition auch das Ministerium und die
Leitung des Ministeriums dass ich jetzt
übernommen habe hat das Projekt
befördert mindestens nicht kritisch
gesehen und das erweist sich als Fehler
es war es war meine Ansicht nach immer
ein Fehler aber den Beweis sehen wir
jetzt und damit haben die Grünen
erfolgreich diese ampelregierung
wenigstens in dieser Hinsicht eines
Besseren belehrt
es geht hier nicht um belehren es geht
darum dass man jetzt alle auch
diejenigen die Befürworter dieses
Projektes waren sehen dass Energie in
Zeiten wie diesen nie nur ein
wirtschaftspolitisches Projekt ist
sondern immer auch machtpolitische
bedeutsam ist konnotiert werden muss
dass es immer geopolitische Auswirkungen
und Einflüsse hat und die Konsequenz die
wir dann ja am Montag gezogen haben ist
dass eine veränderte Wirklichkeit eine
veränderte Beurteilung der Wirklichkeit
nach sich ziehen muss in meinem
Ministerium liegt eine Säule für die
potenzielle und jetzt erstmal absehbar
nicht erfolgt werdende Genehmigung für
nostream 2 nämlich der sogenannte
versorgungssicherheitsbericht das ist
ein Dokument dass die letzte
Bundesregierung am letzten Tag als sie
noch nicht geschäftsführenden Amt war
verabschiedet hat und damit festgestellt
hat das nostream 2 die
Versorgungssicherheit Deutschlands nicht
gefährdet das war allerdings vor dem
Winter vor dem Krie vor dem Angriff auf
die Ukraine und jetzt muss dieses dieser
Bericht neu geschrieben werden nun ist
alles ganz anders habe ich ein Drittel
unseres Öls und die Hälfte des Gases
kommt aus Russland wie soll diese Lücke
jetzt gefüllt werden
indem wir und das haben wir jetzt schon
seit zwei Monaten getan ohne groß
darüber zu reden die strategischen
Reserven die Gasspeicher auffüllen indem
wir selber kaufen und Leute animiert
haben zu kaufen deswegen kann ich jetzt
sagen wir kommen durch gut durch diesen
Winter wir haben kein Problem mit den
gasspeichern das gilt selbst dann wenn
die Liefermengen aus Russland noch
zurückfallen würden
perspektivisch müssen wir vieles ändern
wir müssen den Gasmarkt stärker
regulieren so dass die Politik meinen
Wenigkeit ein Einfluss darauf hat dass
die Gasspeicher zu Beginn des Winters
gefüllt sind das muss man sich mal klar
machen das haben wir nicht ja es ist ein
völlig die regulierter Markt wir können
im Grunde nur daneben stehen als
Politikerinnen und Politiker die ja
Verantwortung für die
Versorgungssicherheit des Landes tragen
und hoffen dass der Winter nicht zu kalt
wird ein inakzeptabler Zustand würde ich
sagen wir müssen uns so gut wir können
von der Verbrennung von fossilen Gas
befreien und nicht noch den Einbau von
Gasheizung wie es bisher noch noch
passierte mit öffentlichen Geld fördern
wir müssen den Hochlauf von Wasserstoff
so schnell wie es geht organisieren und
wir müssen die bezugswege für Gas
diversifizieren das heißt also
Flüssiggas aus weiteren Staaten nach
Europa nach Deutschland bringen Handel
durch Wandel auch das ein Stichwort an
diesem Abend ist diese Idee in ihren
Augen auch gescheitert Herr Habeck ist
es nicht mehr möglich zu hoffen dass
sich starten wie China Staaten wie
Russland mit wirtschaftlichen
Beziehungen überhaupt noch verändern
lassen und was werden diese Sanktionen
jetzt eigentlich Putin aufhalten und an
dem Schicksal der Ukraine verändern die
Idee des Handels des Handels durch
Handels ist nicht heute abend gestorben
sondern schon in den letzten Jahren
dass man hat gesehen dass ich
Marktwirtschaft und Kapitalismus und
Demokratie nicht automatisch
verschwestern sondern es gibt Systeme
die marktwirtschaftlich sehr erfolgreich
sind und trotzdem Diktatoren und
Despoten als
als Führer in ihrem Land haben und in
letzter Zeit zunehmend mehr das ist also
keine Erkenntnis des heutigen Abends
sondern Naivität der Vergangenheit
gewesen
und dann noch mal die Frage danach was
wir tatsächlich tun können in mit Blick
auf die Zukunft in Sachen Sanktionen die
sollen jetzt so scharf und so
unvorhersehbar und so hart sein wie sie
noch nie waren wird das Putin davon
abhalten seinem Plan zu vollziehen nein
das denke ich nicht das ist ja schon
vorher angekündigt worden aber es wird
im besten Fall dazu führen dass Russland
daran gehindert wird weiteres Unheil
anzurichten indem es mittelfristig schon
von der technologischen Entwicklung
abgeschnitten wird es wird dazu führen
dass der Wohlstand der Mittelschicht in
Russland deutlich reduziert wird und es
wird dazu führen dass die Menschen um
putinen die Kaste um Putin wenn ich so
reden darf
deutliche Einschränkungen in Freiheit
und Vermögen spüren wird
wir danken für dieses Gespräch heute an
diesem Abend Robert Habeck war das der
Vizekanzler des
deutschen Landes und damit sind wir hier
in der Runde und ich gebe nochmal eine
nächste Frage an Erich Vath
Brigadegeneral adét wir hören gerade von
Joe Biden aus Washington den Satz des
der Westen den Krieg um die Ukraine
nicht führen wird und das ist es genau
was Wladimir Putin meint
also ich habe den Eindruck nach dem
Versprecher des amerikanischen
Präsidenten Mitte Januar auf der
Pressekonferenz in Washington wo er so
durchblicken ließ naja wenn das eine
minimal-invasive Geschichte ist in der
Ukraine dann schaut er darüber hinweg
das war für mich schon sehr bezeichnet
nur eine kleine
Invasion wäre dann würde der besten
sowieso einfach sehen wie die Amerikaner
das weiter
interpretieren und
ob das in ihrem in ihrer Bewertung immer
noch eine kleine Lösung ist wenn er
tatsächlich mit seinen Truppen auch
wieder rausgeht nach einer Besetzung
auch der Westukraine und und von Kiew
darauf da muss man einfach abwarten wie
Amerika drauf reagiert wir haben im
Moment eine schwierige Situation ich
meine wir haben einen Donald Trump der
noch Putin vor kurzem gelobt hat als
genial bezeichnet hat was sein Vorgehen
anbelangt und wir wissen auch nicht in
drei Jahren wie die Situation dann in
den USA ist und auch mit Blick auf
Frankreich wir haben da die Wahlen im
April nicht wir haben eine neue deutsche
Regierung das hat alles Putin in seinen
Kalkül auch einbezogen deswegen denke
ich mal aus seiner Sicht war es der
richtige Moment
diese Aktion hier durchzuziehen die
Schwäche einfach zu nutzen wir sind in
Goslar jetzt verbunden mit Sigmar
Gabriel dem ehemaligen Außenminister und
Vorsitzenden der Atlantikbrücke ich
hoffe dass sie mich hören guten Abend
nach Goslar Sigmar Gabriel
guten Abend wir sind zum Zuschauen
verdammt Herr Gabriel
wir müssen nicht zuschauen aber das
einzige was wir nicht können und das ist
ja mehrfach auch zurecht gesagt worden
ist der Ukraine militärisch beistehen
weil wir damit unmittelbar in einen
Konflikt der NATO mit der nuklear macht
Russland kommen würden das kann niemand
wollen das wird doch die Ukraine nicht
wollen und deswegen sind wir jedenfalls
was die militärische Seite angeht zum
Zuschauen verdammt aber wir haben ja
Gott sei Dank noch eine Reihe von
anderen Möglichkeiten allerdings nicht
kurzfristig wirkende wir werden uns auf
einen langen Weg einstellen müssen und
wir werden die Sanktionen die
hoffentlich härter sind als in der
Vergangenheit die werden wir lange
durchhalten müssen bis sie Wirkung
erzielen wir haben dem Präsidenten
Russlands zuhören können der damit
drohte dass es Konsequenzen geben würde
wie Sie sie in der Geschichte noch nie
erlebt haben wenn es der Westen wagen
würde sich in diese angeblich innere
russische Angelegenheit einzumischen was
meint er damit er fühlt
oder er spielt mit seinen atomaren
Waffen
sicher dass was er sagt ist er das was
auch Joe Biden und alle anderen auch
befürchten dass würden wir militärisch
gegen Russland Vorgehen dann würde das
zu einem Krieg mit der nuklear macht
Russland führen und
ihr anwesender general ade wird wissen
besser als ich dass die russische
Militär Doktrin ungefähr so ist wie die
westliche der NATO in den 60er und 70er
Jahren nämlich dass der Einsatz von
Nuklearwaffen am Anfang einer
militärischen Konfrontation mit der NATO
steht und nicht etwa am Ende so ähnlich
haben wir in den härtesten Zeiten des
Kalten Krieges auch gedacht und deswegen
versuchen alle diese Konfrontation zu
vermeiden weil die keiner gewinnen kann
aber ich es ist ja schwierig an einem
solchen Tag oder Abend was
optimistisches zu sagen aber ich finde
eins ist auch klar der Westen hat schon
einmal mit langem Atem einen Gegner
besiegt nicht durch militärische Mittel
sondern indem er ihm wirtschaftlich
kulturell polit überlegen war und ich
finde es gibt überhaupt keinen Grund zu
glauben dass uns das kein zweites Mal
gelingt aber nochmal wir würden einen
langen Atem brauchen weil natürlich will
er die mehr Putin einkalkuliert die
Sorge vor einer wirtschaftlichen
Rezession die hohen Energiepreise die
wirtschaftliche Schwäche in einigen
Teilen Europas die Zerrissenheit Europas
zwischen Ost und West er testet jetzt ob
diese Einheit in Europa mit den USA
sozusagen stabil ist und wir tun gut
daran im zu beweisen dass sie stabil ist
aber das wird auch bedeuten dass wir
vieles machen müssen um Europa zu
stabilisieren denn wenn die Sanktionen
Rückwirkungen haben die sozusagen zur
wirtschaftlichen Katastrophe in einigen
Ländern Europas führen dann wird es
schwer das ist glaube ich die Aufgabe
die auch vor uns liegt nicht nur
gegenüber Russland was zu tun sondern
auch gegenüber unseren eigenen
europäischen Nachbarn und auch in
unserer eigenen Bevölkerung und damit
sind wir Melanie Ammann bei der Frage
Spiegel Chefredaktion hier in Berlin
werden die Menschen in Deutschland so
bereitwillig folgen wir haben Robert
Habeck gehört wir hören jetzt Sigmar
Gabriel wenn es tatsächlich auch
Opfer fordern wird und uns etwas kosten
wird sind die Menschen in Deutschland
bereit diesen Preis zu zahlen wenn sie
es sich nicht wenn sie es sich leisten
können also da fragt sich welche
Menschen sie meinen sind es die die
wirklich auf den Preis gucken müssen
wenn Sie Ihren Tank voll machen oder
sind es die wie wir wenn man ehrlich
sind die es nicht spüren ob jemand also
ob die Preise jetzt erhöht wurden oder
nicht und ich glaube schon dass die
Menschen die das im Portemonnaie extrem
spüren die wirklich hingucken müssen
wofür gebe ich was aus wie warm darf ich
die Heizung hochstellen wie muckelig da
wie es mir zu Hause machen aus
Solidarität mit der Ukraine oder soll
ich ein bisschen frieren ich glaube ich
glaube nicht dass da der Druck lange auf
sich warten lassen wird auf die
Regierung und das hat natürlich Herr
Habeck vorhin in seinem Statement ein
bisschen außer Acht gelassen oder
zumindest unter den Tisch fallen lassen
was das für Folgen hat eben dieser an
sich völlig richtige Impuls zu sagen
jetzt müssen wir da raus und wir haben
eine sehr ehrgeizige sind ja auch
Stützungsmaßnahmen jetzt ergriffen
worden das hat er tatsächlich nicht
erwähnt also die Subventionierung
notwendig sein werden notwendig sein das
ist gar keine Frage und wir sind
natürlich auch in der Situation
diese Programme jetzt schnell zu
brauchen weil der Gaspreis aus ganz
anderen Gründen noch in diesen
unglaublichen Höhen ist aber nochmal zu
der Frage man würde sich vielleicht ja
auch wünschen dass es noch mehr
Demonstrationen auf den Straßen gibt
Frau Ammann ist es irgendwie es klingt
hilflos aber man könnte ja auch sagen
ich demonstriere jetzt dagegen dass
Putin einen die Ukraine überfallen hat
ein europäisches Land überfallen hat
sollte man denken also ich weiß nicht ob
es daran liegt dass die Friedensbewegung
eine tendenziell eher linke Bewegung ist
und man dort vielleicht eher eine
gewisse Grund Sympathie für Russland
hegt also wenn man an die Partei DIE
LINKE denkt also die mussten sich ja
doch sehr viel Zeit nehmen um sich dann
durchzuringen zu einer klaren
Verurteilung der von put Politik also
vor Montag hat man da ja noch eher das
Gegenteil gehört und
ein bisschen eben sogar zum ehemaligen
Bundeskanzler Gerhard Schröder den ja
auch agabrik gut kennt also das ist ich
würde sagen das ist das könnte schon ein
Grund sein das ist daran wir fragen
Herrn Gabriel gleich sind aber noch mal
bei Herrn Fahrt Sie Herr Vater haben uns
vorhin schon dabei geholfen zu verstehen
warum das eben kein NATO Einsatzfall
nach Artikel 5 ist das heißt putin wird
vermeiden dass es ein Artikel 5 Fall
wird diese Invasion in der Ukraine oder
befürchten sie im Worst Case auch dass
es überschwappen kann auf
NATO-Mitglieder und das ist ein Funken
gibt der
dann auch in einem anderen europäischen
oder eben nato-land für entsprechende
militärische Reaktion sorgt na gut man
kann bei so einem Konflikt nichts
ausschließen aber ich denke er geht sehr
rational vor Putin nicht hysterisch und
auch nicht idiotisch sondern sehr
eiskalt politisch agierend lange geplant
das ganze drehbuchartig gescriptet und
er macht sicherlich nicht den Fehler das
nato-gebiet anzutasten weil er dann weiß
dann kriegt er die geballte Ladung des
Westens ab und das kann er auch
militärisch nicht durchstehen das weiß
er im Grunde lassen wir die Ukraine
militärisch jetzt aber allein und die
NATO-Truppen stehen auch wenn es da
jetzt noch tausend mehr im Baltikum gibt
oder 5000 mehr stehen im Grunde an einer
ganz anderen Grenze als die Russen in
der Ukraine also nun glaube das ist sehr
wichtig ist von Seiten des Westens
Stärke zu zeigen die Abschreckung
hochzufahren nicht die Bündnisse
Solidarität das ist ja ein Prozess ja
auch im Gange ist das ist sehr wichtig
und vor allen Dingen dass man damit auch
impliziert Putin aufzeigt hier ist die
Grenze auch und ich glaube dieser Punkt
ist sehr wichtig und das schaffen wir
nicht mit Wirtschaftssanktionen nicht
sondern wirklich nur mit
hardpower Hardcore Militär macht im
Grunde genommen nicht und das müssen wir
zeigen nicht das müssen wir deutlich
machen damit er bekommen ich glaube das
ist sehr sehr wichtig er ist 70 Jahre
alt er will vielleicht noch was Großes
leisten aus seiner Sicht in seinem
Restleben und dann müssen wir sehr
aufpassen dass das nicht in
Irrationalität und irrationales handeln
dann abgleitet welche und dazu gehört
mediterische Stärke alles andere nimmt
er uns nicht ab und auch das Wort
militärische Abschreckung darüber haben
wir schon geredet sieht man Gabriel die
Frage zu ihnen noch mal zur
sozialdemokratischen Regierung dieses
Landes Olaf Scholz hat ja sehr lange
auch in Bezug auf nordstream 2 von einer
privaten Initiative gesprochen dass viel
hier in der Runde auch schon wie
problematisch ist dass diese
Bundeskanzler da tatsächlich an Fleck
auf der Weste hat oder einen sagen sie
ist es ist eine Frage der
Glaubwürdigkeit
ist erstmal ein Zitat von Angela Merkel
Angela Merkel hat Notdienst zwei immer
als privatwirtschaftliches Projekt
bezeichnet ich übrigens nicht und sie
hat im praktischen Handeln es auch nicht
so gehandhabt denn die Voraussetzung zur
Zustimmung zu Nord Stream 2 war das
Versprechen Putins dass er gebrochen hat
die territoriale Integrität der Ukraine
zu schützen und vor allen Dingen auch
die Transit Pipeline durch die Ukraine
weiter zu nutzen insofern hat sie auch
nicht es als rein privatwirtschaftliches
Projekt in der in der Realität gesehen
aber dieser Spruch kommt aus dieser Zeit
die Wahrheit ist natürlich dass wir vor
25 Jahren den Energiemarkt in Europa so
liberalisiert haben wie er habe ich das
beschrieben hat wir haben einfach vor 25
Jahren gedacht es gibt auch in
Energiepolitik sowas wie eine
Friedensdividende und wir haben den
Staat rausgedrängt aus der Zuständigkeit
für Versorgungssicherheit oder gesagt
haben die Märkte können das besser und
sie konnten es auch lange Zeit besser
und wir haben sehr davon profitiert und
Putin hat dieser Friedensdividende ein
Ende gesetzt wenn Fragen war das naiv
wenn man vom Rathaus kommt immer immer
schlauer damals war das die Überzeugung
aller in Europa dass die Liberalisierung
der Energiemärkte das Richtige ist und
jetzt auf einmal merken wir der Staat
muss zurück in die Verantwortung für die
Versorgungssicherheit und wird jetzt
diversifizieren und Robert hab absolut
recht natürlich haben wir die
Möglichkeit uns unabhängiger zu machen
von russischer Energie allerdings wird
das eben ein preiskosten und ich glaube
die Politik wird in Berlin vieles
überarbeiten müssen was sie sich
eigentlich für die Koalition vorgenommen
hatte aber natürlich auch eine breite
Senkung von Steuern und Abgaben brauchen
damit wir diese
Energiepreisentwicklung abfangen können
sonst werden uns die Bürgerinnen und
Bürger auf Dauer nicht folgen wie lange
kann Gerhard Schröder noch in der
Position bleiben in der er ist Herr
Gabriel vielleicht kann ich so fragen
fragen
das ist momentan nicht möglich aber das
würde dann irgendwie auch sehr dafür
sprechen warum die SPD so lange von
einer privatwirtschaftlichen Initiative
gesprochen hat das ist jetzt die Frage
an Sie welche
welches glaubwürdigkeitsprobleme ich
wäre
ich wäre froh wenn das eine Erklärung
wäre das was ich an Mails und Briefen
bekomme deutet eher darauf hin dass die
Sozialdemokratie in Spiegelbild dessen
ist was in unserer Gesellschaft los ist
es gibt nämlich viele die in der Tat der
politischen Propaganda aufsitzen die
sagen ihr seid doch selbst schuld ihr
habt den Bären gereizt ihr seid viel zu
dicht gekommen und die übrigens
erschreckend herzlos gegenüber dem
Schicksal der Ukrainer sind und ich
glaube ein Teil der politischen Debatte
spiegelt diese gesellschaftliche
Situation in Deutschland wieder vor der
kann man nicht die Augen verschließen
dass ich in der Frage Russlands und der
Ukraine anderer Meinung bin also Gerd
Schröder das ist nun keine neue
Nachricht aber ich wäre fast froh wenn
er mit seiner Position das Problem wäre
ich glaube wir haben ein tiefer
liegendes Problem jedenfalls entnehme
ich das vielen Briefen die ich so jeden
Tag kriege wenn ich mich öffentlich dazu
äußere dass man Putty nicht davonkommen
lassen darf das scheint mir eher ein
gesellschaftliches Problem zu sein und
nicht die Rolle von Gerd Schröder wir
können auch das nicht zu Ende
diskutieren Herr Gabriel dennoch eine
Frage zu ihrem Blick in die Zukunft in
einer ja irgendwie sehr böse Zukunft
wenn man sie sich im schlechtesten Falle
ausmalt sie kennen Wladimir Putin sie
kennen ihn persönlich auch aus vielen
Gesprächen nicht so vielen und nicht so
intensiven wie Gerhard Schröder
logischerweise was halten sie an dem
Plan den er in der Ukraine und mit der
Ukraine vorhat eigentlich noch für
irgendwie beeinflussbare seitens des
Westens
da läuft ein Drehbuch ab mein Eindruck
ist nichts ich kann auch keine
Verbindung herstellen zwischen dem
Wladimir Putin den ich kennengelernt
habe und den den ich heute einer dem den
ich jetzt bei seiner Rede gesehen habe
was er will ist ganz offensichtlich und
es hat nichts mit Sicherheitsfragen zu
tun auch nichts mit der NATO sondern er
will die Chance nutzen Russland zurück
in die Rolle einer Großmacht zu bringen
die über das Schicksal Europas zumindest
mitentscheiden kann das ist das was er
eigentlich will und sein Bild ist eher
das zaristische Russland in dem er
sozusagen die Existenz von eigenen
Nationalitäten negiert und das glaube
ich ist die eigentliche Gefahr er will
Russland in die Machtposition bringen
über Europas Schicksal zu entscheiden
und aus seiner Sicht ist es total normal
dass er darüber mit den USA verhandelt
nicht mit Europa ob wir Europa ist
Objekt seiner Politik und nicht Subjekt
wir haben darüber schon gesprochen Erich
Fahrt Belarus ist im Grunde ja schon
einer dieser Puffer den Wladimir Putin
auf der einen Seite nördlich geschaffen
hat und nun offensichtlich auch mit der
Ukraine vorhatte im Grunde hat er seit
2008 diesen Krieg erklärt und wir haben
es offensichtlich nur nicht hören wollen
oder nicht präzise genug hingehört noch
mal auch an sie an den General die Frage
gibt es irgendetwas was Putin jetzt
aufhalten wird fortzufahren mit dieser
Invasion und einem Lehrbuch nein ich
glaube also sein militärisches vorrücken
werden wir nicht bremsen können und ich
was sie sagen Vollender sehe ich auch so
also ich glaube seine Zielvorstellung
ist tatsächlich so ein eine
rumpf-ukraine ähnlich wie Belarus mit
einer Marionettenregierung ähnlich wie
ein Belarus und ansonsten eben den
Zugriff auf den dombas die
Schwarzmeerküste die ist für ihn
strategisch sehr wichtig damit er eben
wir Kabel richtig sagt auch diesen
großmachtanspruch
überhaupt zeigen kann welche und darum
geht es ihm natürlich wie aussichtsreich
kurze Frage kurze Antwort wie
aussichtsreich werden all die kommenden
Gespräche der Regierungschefs innerhalb
Europas mit der NATO mit Washington sein
wenigstens die hat Putin ja auch
erfolgreich in den letzten Wochen
vorgeführt ich glaube dass ich alle neu
sortieren müssen ich glaube dass wir da
in nächster Zeit erstmal Verwirrung
sehen werden Unsicherheit sehen werden
und ich würde gerne noch was sagen zu
Herrn Gabriel aber wahrscheinlich reicht
die Zeit dafür nicht ich habe das Gefühl
wir haben heute in einer Sendung zwei
Sigmar Gabriels erlebt den einen der
Putin super kennt und uns genau erklärt
was man jetzt machen muss und den
anderen der in dieser Kenntnis über
Jahre auch als Mitglied der Regierung
unsere Abhängigkeit in Energiefragen von
diesem Mann organisiert hat und das
finde ich ein bisschen problematisch wir
können Herr Gabriel darüber jetzt leider
nicht mehr die Chance haben darauf zu
antworten
weil natürlich die Vereinfachung ja
man kann das sich schön einfach machen
wie die Kollegin vom Spiegel indem man
einfach so tut als er das alles
sozusagen ein Fehler der deutschen
Politik noch mal wir haben vor 25 Jahren
in Europa entschieden die Politik hat in
der Energie nichts mehr zu suchen wir
haben das den Märkten überlassen
übrigens an der vollen vordersten von
derjenigen die das gefordert haben weil
die Wirtschaftsredaktion des SPIEGEL
lese es mal nach und jetzt sozusagen zum
weckmessern zusammen alles anders machen
müssen ja das kann man machen aber es
ein bisschen komplizierter als sie zu
tun gegeben aber gut Herr Gabriel wir
müssen Frau Ammann an der Stelle sofort
nach Mainz geben zu den Kollegen im
Mainzer Studio Matthias fornhoff
übernimmt wieder ich darf mich bei Ihnen
bedanken ganz herzlich bedanken für
diese instruktive halbe Stunde und gebe
nach Mainz vielen Dank danke nach Berlin
und willkommen zurück zum zdf-spezial
der russische Angriff auf die Ukraine
geht weiter vor allem Flugplätze und
militärische Einrichtungen sind Ziele so
hat es der ukrainische
Verteidigungsminister gerade gesagt
mittlerweile sind schon hunderttausend
Menschen auf der Flucht sagen die
Vereinten Nationen und gerade eben haben
sich die Staats- und Regierungschefs der
EU auf weitreichende Sanktionen gegen
Russland geeinigt unter anderem in den
Bereichen Energie Finanzen und Transport
zudem soll es Exportkontrollen für
bestimmte Produkte sowie Einschränkungen
bei der Visapolitik geben
es war ein bedrückender Tag an brutaler
Rückschlag für die Friedensordnung in
Europa Putins Militäroperationen quer
durch die Ukraine sind offenkundig noch
nicht am Ende es drohte eine gefährliche
Nacht vor allem in den Städten vor allem
in Kiew wo die russischen Invasoren
erklärtermaßen die Regierung stürzen
wollen
so viel von diesem zdf-spezial wir
halten Sie wie immer auf dem Laufenden
in der ZDFmediathek und auf ZDF heute
und jetzt übernehmen hier die
Kolleginnen und Kollegen vom
heute-journal auf Wiedersehen
[Musik]
über den russischen Einmarsch in der
Ukraine sprechen wir heute unter anderem
mit Vizekanzler Robert Habeck mit
Norbert Röttgen mit Gerhard Baum mit
André Melnik und Alice bota bis gleich
[Musik]